You know that feeling of getting lost in a story you're listening to? The power to spark our imagination is what Audible is all about. Canadian Voices reading best-selling audiobooks, podcasts, and exclusive originals. It's Raz Westin from the Razumoka Show podcast. Welcome to A Good Listen with a new clip from a recommended title selected by our friends at Audible.ca. Take a good listen to The Rookie Year by Sydney Crosby. If he could be anywhere close to the hype, we were going to be in really good shape. It's hard as a rookie coming in with that kind of spotlight.
你知道那种沉浸在所听故事里的感觉吗？能够激发我们想象力的力量正是Audible的宗旨。加拿大之声为您朗读畅销有声书、播客和独家原创。我是《拉祖莫卡秀》播客的雷兹·韦斯汀。欢迎收听《好书悦听》，节目将为您播放来自Audible.ca推荐书单的最新精彩片段。请认真聆听西德尼·克罗斯比的《新秀年》。如果他的表现能稍微契合那些炒作，那我们的情况就会非常乐观。作为一名新秀，顶着那种聚光灯入场是非常艰难的。
It becomes much more real when you get to United Jail. I mean, the stakes are much higher. Immediately you think, is this Sydney Crosby thing going to pan out? Like, are they going to become good? You couldn't have crammed as many things into one season. It was crazy. It becomes much more real when you get to United Jail. To hear more, join and listen for free for 30 days.
当你真正来到United Jail时，一切就变得真实多了。我是说，赌注高得多了。你马上就会想，这个西德尼·克罗斯比真的能成功吗？也就是说，他们会变强吗？你不可能把这么多的事情全塞进一个赛季里。这太疯狂了。当你真正来到United Jail时，一切就变得真实多了。想要收听更多内容，请加入并免费畅听30天。
Find this title and over 800,000 more at Audible.ca. There's more to imagine with Audible. Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Sheperton was used as a popular river crossing during the 1850s gold rush, allowing miners to travel east from the Bendigo and Ballarat gold fields. By the 1960s, the township had grown exponentially due to a large number of southern European immigrants that settled in the area in the previous century. Sheperton became the central entertainment hub for surrounding rural communities
在Audible.ca寻找这本书以及其他超过80万部精彩作品。Audible带给你无限想象空间。请在您的应用程序或我们的网站上查看本集的节目简介。在1850年代的淘金热期间，谢珀顿曾是一个热门的渡河点，允许矿工们从本迪戈和巴拉瑞特金矿向东出行。到了1960年代，由于上一世纪有大量南欧移民在该地区定居，该镇的人口呈指数级增长。随着汽车影院、星光保龄球馆的开业，以及新市民中心的开发，谢珀顿成为了周边乡村社区的中心娱乐枢纽，
following the opening of a drive-in movie theater, the Star Bowling Alley, and the development of a new Civic Center, which gave the 15,000 locals a venue to hold public events, concerts, and dances. On the night of Thursday, February 10, 1966, the Civic Center was hosting a rock and roll concert dubbed the Mod Spectacular. A range of popular music acts were built for the event, drawing in a crowd of 1,500 local and regional teenagers, including 16-year-old Abina Margaret Medill.
这为当地的15,000名居民提供了一个举办公共活动、音乐会和舞会的场所。1966年2月10日星期四的晚上，市民中心正在举办一场名为“摩斯派对”的摇滚音乐会。多场受欢迎的音乐演出被安排在活动中，吸引了1,500名当地和区域青少年的到来，其中包括16岁的阿比娜·玛格丽特·梅迪尔。
Affectionately known to friends and family as Bina, she was raised on a farm in the nearby township of Vantara by her parents, Fred and Dalma. The couple had five children, one son and four daughters, and Abina was their middle child. Their son, Rodney, planned to carry on the family tradition of farming, but the couple felt their daughters needed a wider range of educational, employment, and social opportunities, so they decided to relocate to Sheperton in the early 1960s. Regarded as a spirited, vivacious teenager who always wore a smile, Abina now lived with her family in a violet-colored weatherboard house close to the center of town.
她的亲友们亲切地叫她比娜，她由父母弗雷德和达尔玛抚养长大，在附近旺塔拉镇的一个农场长大。这对夫妇育有五个孩子，一个儿子和四个女儿，阿比娜是他们的中间孩子。他们的儿子罗德尼计划继承家族的农耕传统，但这对夫妇觉得他们的女儿需要更广泛的教育、就业和社会机会，因此他们在1960年代初决定搬到谢珀顿。阿比娜被认为是一个精神饱满、活泼且总是带着微笑的青少年，现在她和家人住在镇中心附近一栋紫色的木板房里。
The Medills were parishioners at a Presbyterian church called St Andrews, and Abina played badminton and tennis at the church's fellowship association. She had recently left high school to start a full-time job as an office clerk at Sheperton Motor Panels, the city's largest panel beaters. Upon finishing work on February 10, 1966, she headed straight home to get ready for the mod spectacular with her younger sister, Roslyn. Abina dressed in a matching blouson skirt, paired with new white sandals and a white shoulder back. At 8.40pm, Fred Medill drove his daughters to Sheperton's Civic Center,
梅迪尔一家是圣安德鲁斯长老会教堂的教友，阿比娜在该教堂的团契协会打羽毛球和网球。她最近刚离开高中，开始在谢珀顿汽车面板厂——该市最大的钣金修理厂——担任办公室职员的全职工作。1966年2月10日下班后，她直接回家，准备和妹妹罗丝琳一起去参加摩斯派对。阿比娜穿着一条相配的布鲁森半身裙，搭配着崭新的白色凉鞋和白色单肩包。晚上8点40分，弗雷德·梅迪尔开车送女儿们去谢珀顿的市民中心，
picking up the girl's two friends, Janice Frost and Ray Croxford, on the way. The group of four were excited for the night ahead. Unable to get a park near the center, Fred dropped the girls off nearby and headed home, comforted by the fact that Abina had arranged for her boyfriend, 18-year-old Ian Urquett, to drive her and her friends home after the concert. Ian, his brother, and his two sisters were raised by their strict Scottish father on a fruit farm just outside Sheperton following the death of their mother 13 years earlier. Driven to succeed and described by his sister Heather as a workaholic,
顺路接了女孩们的两个朋友贾尼斯·弗罗斯特和雷·克罗克斯福德。这四个人对即将到来的夜晚感到兴奋不已。由于无法在中心附近找到停车位，弗雷德把女孩们在附近放下后便驱车回家，心里感到一丝安慰，因为阿比娜已经安排好了她的男朋友、18岁的伊安·厄克特在音乐会结束后开车送她和朋友们回家。伊安、他的兄弟以及两个妹妹在母亲十三年前去世后，由他们严厉的苏格兰父亲在谢珀顿郊外的一个水果农场抚养长大。渴望成功且被他的姐姐希瑟描述为工作狂的
Ian's proficiency for motor mechanics earned him an apprenticeship at a local Ford dealership. His brother, David, had also been offered a role there, and the siblings worked alongside each other. Eager for some independence, Ian moved out of home shortly after commencing his new job and rented a room in a boarding house near the center of Sheperton. He was regarded as a jovial person with a mischievous side and an inclination for pulling playful pranks. Abina Medill was Ian's first real girlfriend, and he already held strong feelings for her. As he was working late at the dealership that Thursday, he was unable to take her to the mod spectacular, but had arranged to meet her there, later in the night.
伊安在汽车机械方面的精湛技艺为他赢得了当地一家福特经销商处当学徒的机会。他的兄弟大卫也在那里获得了一份工作，兄弟俩并肩工作。渴望一些独立性的伊安在开始新工作后不久便搬出了家，在谢珀顿中心附近的一家寄宿公寓租了一个房间。他被认为是一个性格开朗、带有一点调皮恶作剧倾向的人。阿比娜·梅迪尔是伊安的第一个真正女朋友，他对她已经有了强烈的感情。由于那个星期四他在经销商那里加班，他无法带她去参加摩斯派对，但已经安排好当晚晚些时候在那里与她会合。
18-year-old Gary Charles Haywood had been dating his girlfriend Gail for almost a year. Although most of Sheperton's youths were heading out to the concert that evening, shy and soft-spoken Gail opted to forgo the event, preferring to have a quiet night at home instead. Her boyfriend agreed to do the same as he was broke and his paycheck wasn't scheduled to arrive until the following day. Gary dropped Gail off at her house shortly before 6pm, and she assumed he would spend the evening at home as they had discussed. Gary did return home briefly to eat a quick meal, but then decided to attend the concert after all. Tall, handsome and popular, Gary was the oldest son of the prominent and successful Haywood family
18岁的加里·查尔斯·海伍德和他的女朋友盖尔已经交往了将近一年。尽管谢珀顿的大多数年轻人那天晚上都出城去参加音乐会，但害羞寡言的盖尔选择放弃这个活动，宁愿在家度过一个安静的夜晚。她的男朋友也同意这样做，因为他身无分文，薪水要到第二天才能拿到。加里在晚上6点前不久把盖尔送回家，而她以为他会像他们讨论过的那样在家里过夜。加里确实短暂回家吃了一顿快餐，但随后还是决定去参加音乐会。身材高大、英俊且受欢迎的加里是显赫且成功的海伍德一家的长子，
and was employed as a panel beater at their vehicle repair business, the same place where a Beena Madill worked as a clerk. Fun-loving and kind-hearted, Gary enjoyed horse-riding and had previously been a scout leader. He was close with his family, especially his younger brother, 14-year-old Alan, whom he often took on outings. Alan adored Gary and had helped him restore his prized possession, a dark green-colored FJ Holden sedan. Gary meticulously cared for the vehicle and enjoyed driving it around town, relishing the attention it generated. Before Gary headed to the mod spectacular, he and Alan washed his beloved car, and as 7pm arrived, Gary prepared to leave,
并在他们的汽车修理业务中担任钣金修理工，也就是阿比娜·梅迪尔做文员的同一家店。加里热爱生活、心地善良，喜欢骑马，以前曾是一名童子军领队。他和家人很亲密，尤其是他14岁的弟弟阿兰，他经常带弟弟出去玩。阿兰非常崇拜加里，并帮他修复了他最珍爱的财产——一辆深绿色的FJ霍顿轿车。加里一丝不苟地照料这辆车，喜欢开着它在镇上兜风，享受它带来的关注。在加里前往摩斯派对之前，他和阿兰一起洗了他心爱的车；当7点到来时，加里准备出发，
dressing in black trousers, a brown jumper with an orange checked shirt underneath, and desert boots. Alan begged to join him, but Gary gently denied his little brother's request. Upon arriving at the Civic Centre, Rosalind Madill immediately headed in to watch the concert. Abena did not follow her younger sister inside. Instead, she and her friend Janice walked around the corner where they had agreed to meet Abena's colleague, Gary Haywood. Gary had parked his FJ Holden outside the front of the Star Bowling Alley on Friar Street and was in the company of three friends, Victor, Paul and Lindsay. The four were sitting inside the vehicle when Abena and Janice arrived. The girls got in and Gary drove the group a short distance
他穿着黑色长裤、一件里面套着橙色格子衬衫的棕色毛衣，以及沙漠靴。阿兰恳求加入，但加里温柔地拒绝了小弟弟的请求。到达市民中心后，罗丝琳·梅迪尔立刻径直走进去观看音乐会。阿比娜没有跟着妹妹进去。相反，她和她的朋友贾尼斯走到拐角处，她们和阿比娜的同事加里·海伍德约定在那里见面。加里把他的FJ霍顿停在弗赖尔街星光保龄球馆正前方外面，同行还有他的三个朋友维克托、保罗和林赛。当阿比娜和贾尼斯到达时，这四个人正坐在车里。女孩们上了车，加里开车把大家开了一小段路
to Victoria Park Lake, close to the heart of the city, arriving a little after 9pm. The park lands surrounding the water had been a grazing paddock before they were transformed into public gardens with a swimming pool built into the lake itself. At night, the area was a popular lover's lane for local teens and young adults. When Gary pulled up, there was a station wagon with two couples inside, parked nearby with its lights on and another car next to it. Gary parked by the pool and the boys drank beer and offered Abena and Janice cans of vodka with orange juice. Janice had one and Abena drank a few, making her somewhat giddy and unsteady. The girls got out of the car to get some fresh air and visit the public toilets close by.
来到了靠近市中心的维多利亚公园湖，到达时刚过晚上9点。环绕水域的公园绿地在被改造成带有建在湖中游泳池的公共花园之前曾是一个放牧场。到了晚上，这个地区是当地青少年和年轻成人的热门幽会场所。当加里把车停下时，附近停着一辆里面有两对情侣的旅行车，车灯亮着，旁边还有另一辆车。加里把车停在泳池旁，男孩们喝着啤酒，并递给阿比娜和贾尼斯几罐加了橙汁的伏特加。贾尼斯喝了一罐，阿比娜喝了几罐，这让她有点头晕目眩、站立不稳。女孩们下车呼吸新鲜空气并参观附近的公共厕所。
As the boys were becoming rowdy, Janice expressed the desire to walk back to the Civic Centre, concerned that Gary appeared the most affected by the alcohol. Abena was reluctant to make the almost 2km long journey on foot as she was wearing new shoes. They returned to the car and within half an hour of arriving at the lake, Gary agreed to drive everyone back to the Civic Centre. He and Lindsay entered the building to watch the concert, while Abena, Janice, Victor and Paul went for a walk around the block. When they returned, they climbed back into the holden where Gary was waiting. Janice was growing increasingly frustrated, complaining to Abena several times that she
由于男孩们开始变得喧闹，贾尼斯表达了想要走回市民中心的愿望，她担心加里看起来受酒精影响最大。阿比娜由于穿着新鞋，很不情愿步行走完将近2公里的路程。她们回到车里，在到达湖边大约半小时内，加里同意开车把所有人送回市民中心。他和林赛进建筑里看音乐会，而阿比娜、贾尼斯、维克托和保罗则去街区散步。当他们回来时，他们爬回了加里正在等候的霍顿车里。贾尼斯越来越沮丧，向阿比娜抱怨了好几次她
wanted to leave as Paul was, quote, molesting her. At around 10.30pm, she exited the vehicle, leaving Abena in the back seat and walked to the Civic Centre alone. To her relief, she spotted her boyfriend and after a short while, the couple decided to leave, driving past the location where Gary Haywood had last parked his FJ Holden, only to notice it was now gone. Ian Urquhart was eager to impress his girlfriend Abena and wanted to be on time to pick her up before the mod spectacular ended at 11.20pm. After leaving work and freshening up at home, Ian walked over to the Taverna Coffee Lounge to join some friends.
想离开，因为保罗在“调戏”她（引述）。大约晚上10点30分，她下了车，把阿比娜留在后座上，独自一人走向市民中心。令她宽慰的是，她看到了她的男友，片刻之后，两人决定离开，开车经过加里·海伍德最后停放FJ霍顿的地方，却发现车已经不见了。伊安·厄克特渴望给女友阿比娜留下好印象，并希望在摩斯派对11点20分结束前准时去接她。下班并在家里梳洗后，伊安步行到塔韦纳咖啡厅与一些朋友汇合。
His friend and housemate Peter Hazelman then drove him to the Civic Centre, where they spotted Abena's sister Roslyn. When she explained that Abena was out driving with Gary Haywood, Ian became noticeably angry. He knew Gary worked with his girlfriend, and struck with jealousy, he shouted that he would, quote, kill the bastard. I'll belt him. Ian and Peter took Roslyn home, where they learned Abena was not back yet. The young man drove around town on the lookout for Gary's FJ Holden, and failing to spot the car, returned to Abena's house and waited out front for her return. Alma Medill had been visiting friends for the evening. When she arrived home after 1am,
他的朋友兼室友彼得·黑泽尔曼随后开车送他去市民中心，在那里他们发现了阿比娜的妹妹罗丝琳。当她解释说阿比娜和加里·海伍德出去兜风时，伊安明显变得生气了。他知道加里和他的女友在同一地方工作，妒火中烧的他大喊他要“杀了那个混蛋”（引述）。“我要狠狠揍他。”伊安和彼得送罗丝琳回家，在那里他们得知阿比娜还没回来。这个年轻人在镇上开车寻找加里的FJ霍顿，没能看到车后，便回到了阿比娜家，在门前等她回来。阿尔玛·梅迪尔晚上一直在拜访朋友。当她在凌晨1点多回家时，
she was surprised to discover her daughter Abena hadn't yet returned from the concert. In a panic, she woke her husband Fred to express her concern. When Abena failed to show up by 2am, Fred drove to Shepardon Police Station to alert them to his daughter's absence, but the building was deserted as the two night shift officers were out on patrol. He returned home to try calling the police instead, and managed to get through to night patrolman Constable Frank Eyre. In the three years Constable Eyre had worked in Shepardon, his job had been mostly routine. The evening of February 10 was shaping up to be another uneventful night, until he received a call from Fred Medill expressing his concern for his daughter
她惊讶地发现女儿阿比娜还没从音乐会回来。她惊慌失措地叫醒丈夫弗雷德，表达她的担忧。当阿比娜在凌晨2点仍未出现时，弗雷德开车前往谢珀顿警察局报告女儿失踪，但大楼空无一人，因为两名夜班警员都在外巡逻。他回到家试图打电话报警，并成功接通了夜班巡警弗兰克·艾尔警员。在艾尔警员在谢珀顿工作的三年里，他的工作大部分是例行公事。2月10日晚本来会是又一个平静无事的夜晚，直到他接到弗雷德·梅迪尔的电话，表达了他对女儿
Abena. Constable Eyre and his partner Constable John Quirk arrived at the Medill house to get the particulars, then headed out to check popular horns to see if Abena was at any. After a fruitless search, the policeman returned to the Medill house, where her family had since learned that Abena was in the company of Gary Haywood. Police drove to the Haywood residence and informed Gary's father Charlie of the situation. The bedroom Gary shared with his younger brother was checked, but his bed was empty. Charlie and Alan Haywood joined Fred Medill and the Constables in searching for the young pair. Checking cars parked outside motels and other locations they thought the teenagers might be. They found no sign of them and by 3am
阿比娜的担忧。艾尔警员和他的搭档约翰·奎克警员来到梅迪尔家了解详情，然后出发去检查热门聚集地，看看阿比娜是否在其中某处。在一无所获的搜寻后，警察回到了梅迪尔家，此时她的家人已经得知阿比娜和加里·海伍德在一起。警察开车去了海伍德的住所，并将情况通知了加里的父亲查利。检查了加里和弟弟共用的卧室，但他的床是空的。查利和阿兰·海伍德加入了弗雷德·梅迪尔和警员们的行列，一起寻找这对年轻的情侣。他们检查了停在汽车旅馆外以及他们认为青少年可能去的其他地方的汽车。他们没有发现任何踪迹，到了凌晨3点，
Fred Medill headed back to the police station to formally report his daughter as missing. The link between Gary and Abena puzzled both families. Although Gary had worked with and befriended Abena, he never mentioned her to his father, nor had Abena spoken of Gary to her family. Charlie returned home and started contacting his son's friends to see whether they could shed more light on the night's events. Witness reports revealed that as Abena sat in his car at the Civic Centre, Gary asked his friends to get out so he could drive her back to the lake and park by the banks of the Gulban River, the spot known locally as a lover's lane. Gary promised his friends he would return later to take them home and gave them a set of his keys
弗雷德·梅迪尔返回警察局正式报告女儿失踪。加里和阿比娜之间的联系让两个家庭都感到困惑。尽管加里和阿比娜共事并成为朋友，但他从未向父亲提及她，阿比娜也从未向家人提起过加里。查利回到家，开始联系他儿子的朋友，看看他们能否为当晚的事件提供更多线索。目击者的证言显示，当阿比娜坐在市民中心他的车里时，加里请他的朋友们下车，以便他可以开车送她回湖边，把车停在古尔本河岸边，这个地方在当地被称为幽会林荫道。加里向朋友们承诺他稍后会回来接他们回家，并交出一套钥匙
and Abena's wristwatch as a guarantee of their intention to return. The pair were last seen driving off together in Gary's FJ Holden. Gary kept his word, returning to the Civic Centre within half an hour, but his friends had since departed. When the concert ended shortly before 11.30pm, a witness saw Gary drive past the centre, but didn't notice if there was anyone else in the car. Constable's air and quirk searched for hours with no results. They suspected the teenagers had spent the night together and there was no cause for alarm. Constable Quirk's shift ended at 5am, so Constable Air gave him a lift home before returning to the police station. As he drove back towards town, he sighted Gary's green FJ
和阿比娜的手表作为他们打算回来的保证。两人最后一次被看到是一起开着加里的FJ霍顿离开。加里信守承诺，在半小时内回到了市民中心，但他的朋友们当时已经离开了。当音乐会在11点30分前不久结束时，一位目击者看到加里开车经过中心，但没有注意到车里是否还有其他人。艾尔和奎克警员搜寻了几个小时，结果一无所获。他们怀疑青少年们在一起过夜，因此没有引起恐慌的必要。奎克警员的班次在凌晨5点结束，所以艾尔警员顺路送他回家，然后返回警察局。当他开车返回镇上时，他看到了加里绿色的FJ
Holden parked haphazardly in Windham Street opposite Victoria Lake. It was about 5 feet from the curb, its engine was cold, the tank was half empty and its windows were down. A blue checkered rug Gary kept folded in the back seat was missing, as were the ignition keys. Charlie Haywood knew his son loved the car and would never abandon it in such a careless manner. The discovery of Gary's vehicle sparked a widespread police search, one of the largest in Victoria at the time. They were assisted by the missing teens' families, with the Haywoods even taking their pet terrier along to see if she could detect Gary's scent. Friends, locals and out of towners alike volunteered as well.
霍顿随意地停在维多利亚湖对面的温德姆街上。它距离路边约5英尺，发动机冰凉，油箱半空，车窗降下。加里折叠放在后座上的一条蓝色格子地毯不见了，点火钥匙也不见了。查利·海伍德知道他的儿子很爱这辆车，绝不会以如此粗心的方式抛弃它。加里座驾的发现引发了一场广泛的警察搜寻，这是维多利亚州当时规模最大的搜寻之一。失踪青少年的家属也参与了协助，海伍德一家甚至带上了他们的小梗犬，看看它是否能闻到加里的气味。朋友、当地人和外地人也都志愿加入。
Some speculated the couple had run off together, but those who knew them didn't believe this to be the case, describing Gary and Abinah as casual acquaintances. Both were well known and highly regarded in Shepparton and neither had expressed a want or need to leave. Moreover, those who knew Gary were certain he would never abandon his beloved Holden. After the car was discovered, the Haywood family drove it home and parked it on their front lawn. Later that morning, Gary's brother Alan started his regular routine of washing the vehicle, spraying its boot with water from a hose. Realising his son's actions could destroy valuable evidence, Charlie quickly stopped Alan before he progressed any further.
有人猜测这对情侣私奔了，但认识他们的人并不相信这一点，他们将加里和阿比娜描述为普通熟人。两人在谢珀顿都广为人知且备受尊崇，且都没有表达过离开的意愿或需求。此外，认识加里的人都确信他绝不会抛弃他心爱的霍顿。汽车被发现后，海伍德一家把它开回家，停在前草坪上。那天早上晚些时候，加里的弟弟阿兰开始了他洗车的日常常规，用软管将水喷向车尾箱。意识到儿子此举可能会破坏重要证据，查利赶紧在阿兰继续之前阻止了他。
Ex-homicide squad detective Peter Parkinson was considered Shepparton's toughest cop. He took charge of the investigation into the disappearance of Abinah Madill and Gary Haywood. Described as old school, aggressive and at times excessive, Detective Parkinson was results-driven and uncompromising in his job. He was already familiar with Gary Haywood and knew how much he loved his car, as he lived around the corner from the family and regularly saw the young man washing it when he passed by. Mindful that Gary would never ditch the Holden by choice, one of Detective Parkinson's first actions was to seize the vehicle and examine it for evidence.
前凶杀案调查组侦探彼得·帕金森被认为是谢珀顿最硬派的警察。他负责接手调查阿比娜·梅迪尔和加里·海伍德的失踪案。被形容为老派、具有攻击性且有时过激的帕金森侦探是一个结果导向且在工作中毫不妥协的人。他对加里·海伍德已经很熟悉，也深知他有多爱他的车，因为他就住在海伍德家拐角处，经常在路过时看到这个年轻人洗车。考虑到加里绝不会主动抛弃霍顿，帕金森侦探采取的首要行动之一就是扣押这辆车并对其进行证据检查。
Two unidentified fingerprints pointing downward were detected on top of the driver's side door, an important discovery the police kept under wraps. On the morning of Saturday, February 12, an elderly man was cycling along a bridge spanning Castle Creek located 22km south of Shepparton and adjacent to the Galbin Valley Highway. He spotted a woman's white leather shoulder bag lying in the dry creek bed below and took it to the local police station. It contained a £1 note, some change, a powder compact, key case, a handkerchief and tissues, as well as a metal disc engraved with the word Billy. The name of Beena Madill was printed on the bag's inside lining alongside her Maxwell
在驾驶员侧车门顶部检测到了两个向下指向的未识别指纹，这是一个警方保密的重大发现。2月12日星期六早晨，一位老人在横跨卡斯尔溪的一座桥上骑自行车，该桥位于谢珀顿以南22公里处，毗邻加尔宾谷公路。他在下方干涸的河床里发现了一个女人的白色皮革单肩包，并把它带到了当地警察局。里面有一张1英镑纸币、一些零钱、一个粉盒、钥匙包、一块手帕和纸巾，以及一个刻有“比利”字样的金属盘。包的内衬上印有比娜·梅迪尔的名字以及她的麦克斯韦
Street address. Suspecting this indicated the 16-year-old had met with foul play, police began piecing together their theory that a Beena had been killed and her body wrapped in the rug missing from Gary's car. Given this spotlighted Gary as a possible suspect, three detectives aggressively grilled his father Charlie, trying to find out whether he was concealing his son from authorities. Meanwhile, the Haywoods home was undergoing a thorough search. Police also questioned Gary's girlfriend Gail, but she could offer nothing of value. By Monday, February 14, additional police resources arrived from Melbourne, including a search and rescue team,
街地址。警方怀疑这表明这名16岁的女孩遭遇了不测，于是开始拼凑他们的理论：比娜被杀害，她的尸体被包裹在加里车里失踪的地毯中。鉴于这使加里成为可能的嫌疑人，三名侦探严厉盘问他的父亲查利，试图查明他是否在向当局隐瞒儿子。与此同时，海伍德的家正在接受彻底搜查。警方还盘问了加里的女友盖尔，但她提供不出任何有价值的信息。到2月14日星期一，来自墨尔本的额外警察资源抵达，包括搜救队、
police divers and a light aircraft. More than 100 volunteers were now involved in the efforts to find the pair, including all the employees of the Haywoods panel beaters. Although no bodies had been located, Melbourne's Homicide Squad also arrived in Shepardon to assist in the investigation. By now, the story had reached the front page of the Shepardon news and was even making headlines in Melbourne. Rumours spread that a fight at the mod spectacular might have something to do with Gary and a Beena's disappearance. Police appealed for a group of Melbourne rock and roll fans who had attended the show to come forward, but the lead went nowhere. On the sixth day of the search, the questioning of a local 16-year-old led detectives to the suburban strip of St Andrews Road,
警察潜水员和一架轻型飞机。已有100多名志愿者参与了搜寻这对情侣的行动，包括海伍德钣金修理厂的所有员工。尽管尚未找到尸体，但墨尔本凶杀案调查组也抵达谢珀顿协助调查。此时，这则报道已经登上了《谢珀顿新闻》的头条，甚至在墨尔本成了头条新闻。有传言称，摩斯派对上的一场打斗可能与加里和比娜的失踪有关。警方呼吁参加过该表演的一群墨尔本摇滚乐迷站出来，但这条线索无疾而终。在搜寻的第六天，对当地一名16岁少年的盘问将侦探们引向了圣安德鲁斯路的郊区地带，
where they found an undergarment under a rock. It was initially believed to have belonged to a Beena, but this was later disproved. After further questioning, the youth was released. Although police had been able to quickly determine that the underwear did not belong to a Beena, the story still went public, causing great pain to her family. The search continued for another two days, extending to the rough country along the Gulban River and into the thick bushland around Shepardon. State forest employees took to horseback as fixed-winged aircraft scoured from above, and police divers submerged themselves in the numerous waterholes throughout the region. Volunteers and officers trekked through wild
在那里他们在一块石头下找到了一件内衣。最初人们认为它属于比娜，但这后来被推翻了。经过进一步盘问，这名少年被释放。尽管警方能够迅速确定这件内衣不属于比娜，但这个消息仍然被公开，给她的家人带来了极大的痛苦。搜寻又持续了两天，扩大到古尔本河流域的粗糙乡村以及谢珀顿周围茂密的灌木丛。国家森林雇员骑马搜寻，固定翼飞机从空中俯瞰，警察潜水员则潜入该地区的众多水潭中。志愿者和警官们跋涉在狂野的
six-foot-high grass, with one police officer remarking. If the two teenagers had been murdered and their bodies dumped in the long grass, searches could pass within a few feet of them and not know it. Their efforts were hampered by the number of snakes in the area, with searches killing 13 in a single day. Saturday, February 19 marked nine days since the teenagers had vanished. The region's annual duck hunting season commenced, and shooters were asked to keep an eye out for clues. In particular, the checked blue rug that was missing from Gary's car. Friends of the teenagers were summoned to the police station and underwent intense questioning, while a spade of alleged sightings were reported from all over Victoria and Australia,
六英尺高的草丛中，一名警官评论说：如果这两名青少年被谋杀并被抛尸在高草丛中，搜救人员从他们身旁几英尺处走过可能都毫无察觉。他们的搜寻因该地区的蛇类数量而受阻，搜救人员曾在一天内杀死了13条蛇。2月19日星期六标志着青少年失踪已经过去了九天。该地区的年度鸭子狩猎季开始了，射手们被要求留意线索。特别是加里车里失踪的那条蓝色格子地毯。青少年的朋友们被传唤到警察局接受严厉盘问，同时维多利亚州和澳大利亚各地都报告了一系列所谓的目击事件，
placing the couple in far-flung locations such as Mildura, Corraine, Seil, Wadonga, and Sydney. These supposed sightings gave the Medill and Haywood families hope that their children were still alive. 16 days after Abinah Medill and Gary Haywood vanished, two 17-year-old high school students, Peter and Philip, set out from Melbourne to the small riverside town of Merchison East for a weekend of rabbit shooting. Peter's family originally hailed from the town, and he still visited his grandparents there regularly. At 11am on Saturday, February 26, they arrived at Merchison East Railway Station, more than 30km southwest of Shepardon, and headed to Peter's grandparents' home for morning tea. Afterwards, they set off down the gravel-packed river road,
将这对情侣置于米尔杜拉、科兰、塞尔、沃东加和悉尼等偏远地点。这些所谓的目击事件给梅迪尔和海伍德家族带来了他们的孩子依然活着的希望。在阿比娜·梅迪尔和加里·海伍德失踪16天后，两名17岁的高中生彼得和菲利普从墨尔本出发，前往小河畔城镇东默奇森进行周末的兔子狩猎。彼得的家人最初来自该镇，他仍然定期去那里探望祖父母。2月26日星期六上午11点，他们到达了位于谢珀顿西南30多公里处的东默奇森火车站，前往彼得祖父母的家享用早茶。随后，他们沿着铺满砂砾的河路出发，
cutting across a paddock and climbing over a barbed wire fence to enter the lightly timbered state forest along the Gulban River. The land was leased from the government by a local farmer, and the teens regularly camped on the property during their shooting trips. Upon entering the bushland, the pair noticed a peculiar odor in the air which they presumed was emanating from a dead animal. They carried on, and approximately an hour later returned the same way as they came. It was on their return track that Peter and Philip discovered the source of the odor. The severely decomposed body of a young woman was lying face up in the paddock, her legs apart, and her arms near her sides. She was naked from the waist down and had sustained
穿过一个牧场，翻过一道铁丝网栅栏，进入古尔本河沿岸树木稀疏的国家森林。这片土地是从政府租给当地农民的，这些青少年在狩猎旅行期间经常在该物业露营。一进入灌木丛，两人就在空气中闻到了一种奇怪的气味，他们认为这是散发自某种死去的动物。他们继续前行，大约一个小时后按原路返回。正是在他们的回程路上，彼得和菲利普发现了气味的来源。一名年轻女性严重腐烂的尸体面朝上躺在牧场里，双腿分开，双臂贴近身体。她腰部以下一丝不挂，并遭受了
severe head injuries. Peter alerted the owner of the farmland, who contacted police. When they arrived, the owner informed them that he too had smelt something near a collection of trees in his paddock, about 300 meters from where the female body was bound, but had also assumed it was a dead animal. When examining this area, the police discovered the clothed body of a male under a 30-foot red gum tree. He had a single bullet wound to his left temple. The bodies were those of Abinah Medill, who had been sexually assaulted, then beaten to death, and Gary Haywood, whose skull contained a .22 caliber bullet. The area was immediately cordoned off as members of the Forensic Science Division,
严重的头部伤害。彼得提醒了农田的主人，后者联系了警方。他们到达时，农场主告知他们，他也曾在牧场的一处树丛附近闻到过某种气味，距离发现女性尸体的地方约300米，但也以为是死去的动物。在检查该区域时，警方在一棵30英尺高的红桉树下发现了一具穿着衣服的男性尸体。他的左太阳穴有一处单一的枪伤。这两具尸体分别是阿比娜·梅迪尔的尸体——她遭到性侵后被殴打致死——以及加里·海伍德的尸体，他的头骨中有一颗.22口径的子弹。该地区立即被封锁，法医科学部、
the Search and Rescue Squad, the Homicide Squad, and Sheperton's Crime Investigation Division began the laborious task of searching the 90 acres of paddocks around the crime scene. 64 meters west of Abinah's body were two pairs of her stockings, each tied tightly in a loop of 50 centimeters. Matching fibers found on Gary's trousers indicated that his legs had been bound with the stockings. His jumper was discovered near the stockings, and in addition to being covered in grass seeds, leaves, and bark, there were traces of blood on it. Abinah's skirt and girdle were found neatly folded nearby, with one white shoe next to the pile and one on top. There was also a second-fired .22 caliber cartridge case,
搜救队、凶杀案调查组和谢珀顿犯罪调查处开始在案发现场周围的90英亩牧场进行艰苦的搜查工作。在阿比娜尸体以西64米处有两双她的丝袜，每双都紧紧打成一个50厘米的环。在加里裤子上发现的相配纤维表明他的双腿曾被这些丝袜捆绑。他的毛衣在丝袜附近被发现，除了沾满草籽、树叶和树皮外，上面还有血迹。阿比娜的短裙和束腰带被整齐地折叠在附近，一只白色鞋子放在一堆旁边，另一只在顶部。还有一个第二枚发射过的.22口径弹壳，
indicating that the killer may have shot at Gary twice, but only hit him once. And a black piece of plastic, which detectives believed might have been part of the murder weapon. The keys to Gary's holden were not at the scene, nor was the rug he kept in the car, and his upper dentures were also missing. Investigators ascertained that the assailant had abducted the pair at gunpoint near Victoria Lake. Dust on Gary's car matched samples taken from the paddock, meaning the killer had driven or ordered the teens to drive to the area where their bodies were later found. It appeared as though Gary struggled with his captor before either running off into the thicket of trees or was marched there before being tied up and executed.
这表明凶手可能向加里开枪两次，但只击中了他一次。还有一块黑色的塑料片，侦探们认为这可能是凶器的一部分。加里霍顿车的钥匙不在现场，他放在车里的地毯也不见了，他上面的假牙也不见了。调查人员确定凶手在维多利亚湖附近持枪劫持了这对情侣。加里车上的灰尘与从牧场采集的样本相匹配，这意味着凶手曾开车或命令青少年开车前往后来发现他们尸体的地方。看起来加里在逃入树丛之前曾与他的绑架者搏斗，或者被强行带到那里随后被捆绑并处决。
The perpetrator then returned to Abinah, who was either restrained or unconscious, and proceeded to rape her before bludgeoning her to death. The careless way in which Gary's car was left back in Shepardon suggested the killer had driven it back into town and abandoned it, before or after discarding Abinah's handbag near the Goulburn Valley Highway. Investigating police described the murders as beyond comprehension and the most brutal killing they had ever encountered. The families of the two victims were extremely distraught. Gary Haywood's mother, Margaret, lost a great deal of weight and struggled to maintain the will to live. His brother,
凶手随后回到当时被约束或失去知觉的阿比娜身边，对其实施强奸，然后将其殴打致死。加里汽车被草率地弃置回谢珀顿，这表明凶手曾将其开回镇上并抛弃，时间可能在抛弃阿比娜的手提包于古尔本谷公路附近之前或之后。调查警方形容这些谋杀案令人发指且是他们遇到过的最残酷的杀害。两位受害者的家属悲痛欲绝。加里·海伍德的母亲玛格丽特体重骤降，苦苦维系着活下去的意志。他的兄弟
Alan, was left terrified, thinking the killer would come after him next. Abinah Medeal's father expressed his shock at her murder in his formal police statement, writing, I cannot think of any reason why any person would want to harm my daughter. An extra team of detectives arrived in Shepardon as officers worked upwards of 16 hours a day to hunt down those responsible. The double homicide had left the small and otherwise quiet city reeling and pressure to find the culprits was intense. A $10,000 reward for information was on offer and a rug matching the one that was missing from Gary's car was displayed in the window of a major store in the middle of town. One individual came to police attention
阿兰则惊恐万状，以为凶手下一个就会来找他。阿比娜·梅迪尔的父亲在正式警方笔录中表达了他对女儿谋杀案的震惊，他写道：我想不出任何人要伤害我女儿的任何理由。一支额外的侦探团队抵达谢珀顿，警员们每天工作长达16小时以追捕凶手。这起双重谋杀案让这座原本平静的小城市陷入震惊，寻找凶手的压力极其巨大。悬赏1万元征集线索，一条与加里车里失踪的相似的地毯被陈列在镇中心一家大型商店的橱窗里。一名个人引起了警察的注意，
after a matching rug was spotted in his home. The man, Ian Stanley Loffel, was in his late 30s and told police he had stolen the rug from a dark blue holden with South Australian registration plates parked outside a pub in Marupna, a town six kilometers west of Shepardon. Police spoke with local mechanics to see if they'd seen any vehicles similar to the one Loffel described and found a match. Convinced this was a promising lead, police tracked the vehicle down to a car yard in South Australia, only to find its drivers had airtight alibis for the night of February 10. Police suspected two or more people had committed the crimes. The region's fruit picking season was at its peak and they considered the possibility that the murderers could be among
因为在他的家中发现了一条相配的地毯。这名男子名叫伊安·斯坦利·洛费尔，30多岁，他告诉警察他是从停在谢珀顿以西六公里的小镇马鲁普纳一家酒吧外的一辆挂有南澳大利亚牌照的深蓝色霍顿车上偷来的地毯。警方与当地机械师交谈，看他们是否见过类似洛费尔所描述的车辆并找到了匹配项。坚信这是一条有前途的线索，警方在南澳大利亚的一个车场追踪到了这辆车，结果发现其司机在2月10日晚有严密的不在场证明。警方怀疑有两人或更多人犯下了这些罪行。该地区的果园采摘季正处于顶峰，他们考虑了凶手可能是临时在镇上从事临时工作的
the thousands of workers temporarily in town for casual employment. When investigators asked local orchardists to report any suspicious workers, hundreds of tip-offs came in, but none led anywhere. As such, police were inclined to believe the murders were committed by locals, as the remoteness of the crime scene indicated the killers were familiar with the area. They were soon concentrating on the town's teenagers in particular. There were reports of a party held near the Gulburn River, close to the west side of Victoria Lake on the night of the murders. It involved a car race and ended in a fierce brawl between attendees when one vehicle hit another. Police believed Gary may have been present and participated
数千名工人之一的可能性。当调查人员要求当地果园主报告任何可疑工人时，收到了数百条线索，但无一指向任何结果。因此，警方倾向于认为谋杀案是由当地人犯下的，因为案发现场的偏远表明凶手熟悉该地区。他们很快将注意力集中在镇上的青少年身上。有报道称，在谋杀案当晚，维多利亚湖西侧附近的古尔本河畔举行了一场派对。它涉及一场汽车比赛，并在其中一辆车撞上另一辆车时以与会者之间的一场激烈斗殴告终。警方认为加里当时可能在场并参与了
in the brawl and was then killed by his opponents for revenge. One senior detective told the media, we feel some of the young people in Shepparton know something of the movements of Gary on the night he was murdered. Although many people have come forward and volunteered information, most of the youths we have interviewed have been those we have sought out ourselves. We believe they are not telling all they know. No one raised as much suspicion as Abina's boyfriend Ian Urquhart. He was viewed as a prime suspect due to his jealous outburst after learning Abina had left with Gary Haywood, whom he then threatened to kill over the matter. At the time, the Melbourne Homicide Squad had a
这场斗殴，然后被他的对手为复仇而杀害。一位高级侦探对媒体说：我们觉得谢珀顿的一些年轻人知道加里被谋杀当晚的行踪。尽管许多人挺身而出并自愿提供信息，但我们面谈的大多数年轻人都是我们自己主动寻找的。我们相信他们没有说出他们所知道的全部。没有人比阿比娜的男友伊安·厄克特引起更多的怀疑。由于他在得知阿比娜与加里·海伍德离开后表现出嫉妒爆发，并随后威胁要因此杀死加里，他被视为主要嫌疑人。当时，墨尔本凶杀案调查组拥有
reputation for being hard officers who were tough on criminals, often beating a confession out of a suspect if necessary. Ian was regularly summoned to the station for formal police interviews, during which he was verbally abused, slapped and kicked by detectives. They believed he was assisted by his friend and housemate, Peter Hazelman, who drove him around on the night of the murders. Peter was also questioned and subjected to aggressive treatment at the hands of the police, as were several of their other friends. Despite these heavy-handed tactics, Ian did not admit any involvement in the crime. Detectives presumed he was too tough to crack,
严厉对待犯罪分子的强硬警官声誉，必要时经常对嫌疑人逼供。伊安被定期传唤到警察局进行正式警方盘问，在此期间他遭到侦探的辱骂、耳光和踢打。他们认为他得到了他的朋友兼室友彼得·海泽尔曼的协助，后者在谋杀案当晚开车送他到处跑。彼得也受到了警方盘问和攻击性对待，他们的一些其他朋友也是如此。尽管采取了这些高压手段，伊安并没有承认参与这起犯罪。侦探们推测他太强硬而无法攻克，
with one remarking to a uniformed officer that he had, quote, belted and belted Urquhart, but he will not confess. When Ian's older sister Heather noticed how miserable he was, she asked what the police interviews involved, but he seemed ashamed and refused to answer. Ian confided in friends that he was very scared of the police and what might happen to him. He began burrowing a car from his father or a friend in order to camp out instead of returning home where officers could find him. One day, he arrived home and informed his family he was, quote, going to tell them he did it, to stop the police from hurting him, even though Victorian laws at the time meant
其中一人对一名穿制服的警官评论说，他曾“狠狠地殴打过厄克特”（引述），但他就是不肯认罪。当伊安的姐姐希瑟注意到他有多痛苦时，她问警方盘问涉及什么，但他显得很羞愧并拒绝回答。伊安向朋友吐露，他非常害怕警察以及可能会发生在他身上的事情。他开始向父亲或朋友借车以便露营，而不是回家，因为警官们可以在那里找到他。有一天，他回到家并告知家人他“要告诉他们是他干的”（引述），以阻止警察伤害他，尽管当时维多利亚州的法律意味着
to confession would have most likely resulted in his execution. Heather convinced him not to confess. The funerals for Gary Haywood and Abinah Medill took place on Friday, March 4, 1966, marking the largest memorial services Shepardon had ever seen. Gary's was held at St. Brendan's Catholic Church at 1 p.m., while Abinah's was at Scott's Presbyterian Church two hours later. The city came to a standstill as shops closed for the day, and people gathered to watch while each procession passed by. Both churches were filled to capacity, with mourners spilling out onto the streets. During Abinah's funeral, a grief-stricken Ian Urquhart was sighted standing at the rear of the church with his sister Heather. He had bought a dozen red roses and a card that read,
供认极有可能导致他的死刑。希瑟说服了他不要认罪。加里·海伍德和阿比娜·梅迪尔的葬礼于1966年3月4日星期五举行，这是谢珀顿有史以来规模最大的追悼会。加里的葬礼于下午1点在圣布兰登天主教教堂举行，而阿比娜的葬礼则在两小时后在斯科特长老会教堂举行。由于商店全天关门，人们聚集观看每一场游行队伍的经过，这座城市陷入了停顿。两座教堂都挤满了哀悼者，人群溢出到街道上。在阿比娜的葬礼期间，人们看到悲痛欲绝的伊安·厄克特和他的姐姐希瑟站在教堂后方。他买了一打红玫瑰和一张卡片，上面写着：
with all my love, Ian. The siblings kept their distance to avoid drawing attention to themselves, but once the congregation noticed their presence, suspicious glances and tense whispers were exchanged amongst them. Abinah and Gary were both laid to rest at Shepardon Public Cemetery, their graves located just 20 meters from one another. Several months later, in mid-1966, having failed to obtain the confession they expected, police officially ruled Ian Urquhart out of their investigation. Two detectives visited the home of his sister Heather to inform the family, and reluctantly acknowledged that their questioning of Ian had been particularly tough due to the seriousness of the
带着我所有的爱，伊安。兄妹俩保持距离以避免引起注意，但一旦会众注意到他们的存在，他们之间便交换了怀疑的目光和紧张的耳语。阿比娜和加里都被安葬在谢珀顿公共墓地，他们的墓地相距仅20米。几个月后的1966年中期，由于未能获得他们期望的供认，警方正式将伊安·厄克特从调查中排除。两名侦探造访了他姐姐希瑟的家以通知其家人，并勉强承认由于案件的严重性，他们对伊安的盘问特别严厉。
case. Despite Ian being cleared, the media, community, and some police members still believed him to be guilty. Harassment remained a part of his daily life, leading him and his alleged accomplice, Peter Hazelman, to relocate into state. Ian moved to Western Australia, picking up work on an oil rig before travelling to Singapore for further work. Peter worked on an oil rig off the Victorian coast for two years, but then returned to Shepardon. The town's attitude towards him had not changed, prompting Peter to relocate again, eventually settling in the Northern Territory's capital city of Darwin. The black piece of plastic found at the crime scene was identified as the plug that screwed into the butt end of an American Mossberg-22 self-loading rifle.
尽管伊安被洗清了嫌疑，但媒体、社区和一些警员仍然认为他有罪。骚扰仍然是他日常生活的一部分，导致他和他的疑似同谋彼得·海泽尔曼搬到了外州。伊安搬到了西澳大利亚，在石油钻井平台上找了一份工作，然后前往新加坡寻找更多工作。彼得在维多利亚海岸外的石油钻井平台上工作了两年，但随后返回谢珀顿。该镇对他的态度没有改变，促使彼得再次搬迁，最终定居在北领地的首府达尔文。案发现场发现的黑色塑料片被确认为拧入美国莫斯伯格-.22半自动步枪枪托端部的塞子。
Forensics confirmed the firearm was used to execute Gary Haywood and Bludgeon Abinah Medill, though there were four semi-automatic models that the recovered shells could have come from. Mossbergs were obtainable from most Australian gun dealers, but it wasn't a particularly common weapon. Anyone knowing the whereabouts of any Mossberg semi-automatic firearms were asked to contact the police. Some were confiscated, including a sawn-off version from a 20-year-old who lived close to where the bodies were found. Manufacturers in the United States were asked to supply records of rifles imported to Australia, and police tracked down owners from local gun sellers' records. Once a rifle was found, police fired it to compare against the shell casings,
法医证实，这支枪曾被用来处决加里·海伍德和布利奇恩·阿比娜·麦迪尔，尽管回收的弹壳可能来自四种半自动型号。虽然大多数澳大利亚枪支经销商都能买到莫斯伯格霰弹枪，但它并不是一种特别常见的武器。任何知道莫斯伯格半自动枪支下落的人都被要求联系警方。一些枪支被没收，其中包括从死者尸体被发现地点附近的一名20岁男子那里没收的一把锯短版。美国制造商被要求提供进口到澳大利亚的步枪记录，警方则通过当地枪械销售商的记录追踪到了枪支所有者。找到步枪后，警方将其发射以与弹壳进行比对，
with a total of 353 Mossbergs being tested throughout the investigation. Inquiries began in Shepardon and its surrounds, later expanding to all parts of Victoria and eventually throughout Australia. During this time, a police constable attended a farm in Artmona, a locality in the Gulburn Valley 10km west of Shepardon. He was looking to question a 22-year-old man named Raymond Edmonds after his name came up in one of the investigation's many tip-offs, although the exact reason for the visit was never recorded. The property owner advised the constable that Edmonds, who had lived and worked on the land for the past two years as a share farmer, was no longer in the district as he had recently moved with his wife and their
在整个调查过程中总共测试了353支莫斯伯格霰弹枪。调查从谢帕顿及其周边地区开始，后来扩大到维多利亚州的所有地方，最终扩展到整个澳大利亚。在此期间，一名警员前往古尔本谷谢帕顿以西10公里处的一个名为阿特莫纳的局部的农场。他希望讯问一名名叫雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹的22岁男子，此前他的名字出现在调查的众多线索之一中，尽管此次访问的确切原因从未被记录在案。房主告知警员，埃德蒙兹过去两年来一直在该土地上作为分成农户生活和工作，但已不在该地区，因为他最近和妻子以及他们的
three young children to Mayrong, a small community in southern New South Wales. The property owner provided a forwarding address for Edmonds, and the constable thanked him, adding, we'll get the boys up there to pick him up. After the constable left, the property owner recalled Edmonds owned a 22 semi-automatic Mossberg rifle which he used to go rabbit shooting, and presumed this detail was the reason for the officer's visit. An inquest into the unsolved murders of Gary Haywood and Abina Madill was held in June 1970, four years after the teenager's bodies were found. It had been postponed by the case investigators and when asked why, senior constable Peter Parkinson explained. Inquiries have been at
三个年幼的孩子搬到了新南威尔士州南部的一个小社区迈戎。房主提供了埃德蒙兹的转发地址，警员向他致谢，并补充说，我们会派人上去把他带回来。警员离开后，房主想起埃德蒙兹拥有一把22口径的半自动莫斯伯格步枪，他用这把枪去打兔子，并推测这个细节是警官来访的原因。针对加里·海伍德和阿比娜·麦迪尔未破谋杀案的死因研讯于1970年6月举行，也就是这两名青少年的尸体被发现四年后。该研讯被案件调查人员推迟了，当被问及原因时，高级警员彼得·帕金森解释道。调查在
many stages looking good and to then come to utterly nothing. At many stages we have had great hopes of solving it, but without result. By this stage, inquiries had been made across the country, in Queensland, New South Wales, and South Australia, as well as overseas in the United States. Accepting the breakthrough they were hoping for remained out of reach, the inquest into the double homicide was finally scheduled to commence on Tuesday, June 9. Frank Madill spoke at the inquest, describing his daughter as a normal girl of her years who followed the modern teenage trend. He couldn't think of a reason why anybody would want to harm her. Charlie Haywood described his son as a regular boy who respected his parents and always did as
许多阶段看起来很有希望，但最终却毫无结果。在许多阶段，我们对破案抱有巨大希望，但都无果而终。在此阶段，调查已在全国范围内展开，包括昆士兰州、新南威尔士州和南澳大利亚州，并在海外的美国进行了调查。由于承认他们所希望的突破仍然遥不可及，这起双重谋杀案的死因研讯最终定于6月9日星期二开始。弗兰克·麦迪尔在研讯上发言，将他的女儿描述为一个符合现代青少年潮流的、同龄人中很正常的女孩。他想不出任何人要伤害她的理由。查理·海伍德将他的儿子描述为一个普通的男孩，他尊敬父母，总是按
he was asked. When called to the stand, senior constable Peter Parkinson told the coroner that 3,478 individuals had been interviewed and investigations were still ongoing. After hearing evidence from 16 witnesses, the coroner was unable to offer new evidence or insight, announcing that Gary and Abina were murdered by a person or persons unknown in the early hours of February 11, 1966. Despite being officially cleared, Ian Urquett's name was mentioned at the inquest, with evidence put on the record that he was, quote, very annoyed upon learning Abina had gone driving with Gary. Ian was living in Singapore at the time of the inquest and was not called to give evidence.
要求行事。当被传唤到证人席时，高级警员彼得·帕金森告诉验尸官，已有3,478人接受了讯问，调查仍在进行中。在听取了16名证人的证词后，验尸官未能提供新的证据或见解，宣布加里和阿比娜于1966年2月11日凌晨被一名或多名未知身份的人杀害。尽管伊恩·乌克特被官方洗清了嫌疑，但他的名字仍在研讯中被提及，并且有记录表明，当得知阿比娜和加里一起开车出去时，他“非常恼火”。伊恩在研讯时居住在新加坡，未被传唤作证。
He had built a new life for himself overseas, earning good money working as a maintenance specialist on offshore drilling rigs. Two years later, on Friday, February 11, 1972, almost six years to the day since his girlfriend was murdered, Ian Urquett and a colleague returned to Singapore following a work trip to Sumatra. They disembarked their flight shortly after midnight and left the airport in Ian's vehicle, a cream-coloured MG sports car. While driving down a highway, Ian crashed the vehicle at high speed, killing both himself and his passenger instantly. His funeral was held at Scott's Presbyterian Church, the same place where Abina had been farewelled. One ex-homicide detective involved in the case
他在海外建立了自己的新生活，在海上钻井平台上担任维护专家，赚取了不错的收入。两年后的1972年2月11日星期五，也就是他的女友被谋杀近六年后的几乎同一天，伊恩·乌克特和一位同事在苏门答腊出差后返回新加坡。他们在午夜刚过后下飞机，坐进伊恩的乳白色MG跑车离开机场。在公路上行驶时，伊恩高速撞毁了汽车，导致他自己和乘客当场死亡。他的葬礼在斯科特长老会教堂举行，这也是当年为阿比娜送别的地方。一位参与此案的前凶杀案侦探
commented that Ian got his, quote, just deserts, still believing he was guilty of the crimes. Located nearly 200 kilometres south of Shepardon, is the Melbourne suburb of Donvale. In the 1960s, Donvale was characterised by dense bushland, farms and orchards, but by the early 70s, the area was changing, with clusters of residential homes cropping up in place of the large blocks of rural land. On the evening of Monday, July 26, 1971, 25-year-old Suzanne was at her Donvale home with her three children while her husband was out visiting France. After putting the children to bed, Suzanne decided to mop the kitchen floor, and at around 10pm, she went to fetch some clean water from the laundry.
评论说，伊恩得到了他“应得的下场”，他依然坚信伊恩犯下了这些罪行。位于谢帕顿以南近200公里处，是墨尔本的唐瓦尔代郊区。在20世纪60年代，唐瓦尔代的特点是密集的灌木林、农场和果园，但到了70年代初，该地区正在发生变化，大片农村土地上开始涌现出一簇簇住宅。1971年7月26日星期一晚上，25岁的苏珊和她的三个孩子呆在唐瓦尔代的家中，而她的丈夫则外出拜访法国。哄孩子们上床睡觉后，苏珊决定拖厨房的地板，晚上10点左右，她去洗衣房取一些清水。
When she entered the hallway, she was confronted by a man she initially took to be her husband, until she noticed his face was covered in a mask made from a stocking. He raised his right hand, which held a long butcher's knife, causing Suzanne to scream. The masked intruder told her to keep quiet and explained that he didn't want to hurt her, before backing her into the kitchen and demanding money. He then ordered her to undress. Anticipating what would happen next, Suzanne disclosed that she had recently given birth and still had stitches. The assailant replied that he was just going to tie up her hands and feet, then leave, and ordered her to sit on the floor. After he finished restraining Suzanne's hands
当她走进走廊时，迎面遇到一个男人，她最初以为是她的丈夫，直到她发现他的脸上戴着一只长统袜做成的面具。他举起右手，手里握着一把长长的屠刀，吓得苏珊尖叫起来。蒙面入侵者让她保持安静，并解释说他不想伤害她，随即将她逼退到厨房并索要钱财。然后他命令她脱衣服。预料到接下来会发生什么，苏珊透露她最近刚生完孩子，身上还有缝合线。袭击者回答说，他只是打算绑起她的手脚，然后就离开，并命令她坐在地板上。在他用长统袜绑好苏珊的双手
behind her back with a stocking, he tied her ankles together, then began rubbing her breasts. She screamed loudly, and the man fled. Suzanne managed to untie herself and immediately phoned the police. Two detectives arrived within minutes and soon realized that the assault shared a number of similarities with a rape committed in Donvale 11 days earlier. The suburb of Greensboro lies roughly 17km northwest of Donvale. Four years after the attack on Suzanne, 23-year-old Kathy was spending the night of Friday, January 31, 1975, in her Greensboro home with her two children, while her fiance was away interstate. Kathy and her son were both sleeping in her bed, while her infant daughter slept in a cot in the
在她背后之后，他又把她的脚踝绑在一起，然后开始揉捏她的乳房。她大声尖叫，那名男子仓皇逃跑。苏珊设法解开绳子并立即报警。两名侦探在几分钟内赶到，并很快意识到这起袭击事件与11天前在唐瓦尔代发生的一起强奸案有许多相似之处。格林斯伯勒郊区大致位于唐瓦尔代西北偏北17公里处。在对苏珊的袭击发生四年后，23岁的凯茜于1975年1月31日星期五度过了一个夜晚，她和两个孩子呆在格林斯伯勒的家中，而她的未婚夫则去了外州。凯茜和她的儿子睡在她的床上，而她的小女儿则睡在
nursery. At approximately 4.10 in the morning, Kathy was woken by a noise she thought was her daughter rattling the side of her cot. She listened quietly for several minutes, before hearing the sound again from the direction of the laundry. She switched on her bedroom light, and saw a man standing in the doorway of the bathroom, brandishing a 12-inch knife up high in his right hand. Kathy screamed, then told the intruder that a friend was staying over in the guest room and had likely heard her and called the police. The man responded, It's a lie. No one will see you for a couple of days until your husband gets back. He forced her back to her bed, placed a blanket over her terrified son, and raped her.
婴儿房的小床里。大约凌晨4点10分，凯茜被一阵声音吵醒，她以为是女儿在摇晃婴儿床的栏杆。她安静地听了几分钟，然后再次听到从洗衣房方向传来的声音。她打开卧室的灯，看到一个男人站在浴室门口，右手高高挥舞着一把12英寸长的刀。凯茜尖叫起来，然后告诉入侵者，有一个朋友住在客房里，可能已经听到她的声音并报了警。那男的回应道，这都是谎言。在你丈夫回来之前，没人会看见你几天。他强行将她按回床上，在她惊恐的儿子身上盖了一条毯子，并强暴了她。
Police collected small amounts of evidence from the scene, including the perpetrator's fingerprints consisting of a small count loop on the right-hand index finger and a scarred right-hand pinky. These matched fingerprints recovered from the 1971 Don Valle assault. Two years later, on Monday, February 14, 1977, another sexual assault was reported, this time roughly 55km south in the suburb of Chelsea Heights. The crime scene yielded the same distinctive fingerprints as the Don Valle and Greensboro attacks. Investigators were well aware they were dealing with a serial rapist. Between 1971 and 1979, there were 12 assaults, attempted rapes, and rapes throughout Melbourne attributed to an
警方从现场收集了少量的证据，包括肇事者的指纹，其特征是右手食指上有一个小计数环，右小指上有疤痕。这些指纹与1971年唐瓦尔代袭击案中提取的指纹相吻合。两年后的1977年2月14日星期一，又有一宗性侵案被报告，这次是在大约55公里以南的切尔西高地郊区。犯罪现场提取到了与唐瓦尔代和格林斯伯勒袭击案相同的独特指纹。调查人员非常清楚，他们面对的是一个连环强奸犯。在1971年至1979年期间，墨尔本发生了12起袭击、企图强奸和强奸案，这些案件被认为是一个
unknown attacker police had dubbed the Don Valle Rapist, named after the location his spree had begun. Many of the victims were married women who were either home alone or with their young children when the Don Valle Rapist struck. He appeared to stalk his victims, waiting until he knew they were alone or vulnerable before launching an attack. Police were certain he deliberately targeted young mothers in order to control his victims by threatening to harm their children. Descriptions provided by survivors allowed for the creation of a composite sketch of the rapist which was circulated widely among the police and public. The suspect was between the ages of 34 and 44, had a pasty fair complexion, stood between 5 foot 4 inches to 5 foot 10 inches
身份不明的袭击者所为，警方称其为唐瓦尔代强奸犯，这是以他的作案地点命名的。许多受害者是已婚妇女，在唐瓦尔代强奸犯作案时，她们要么独自在家，要么带着年幼的孩子。他似乎在寻找猎物，等到确知她们独自一人或毫无防备时才发动袭击。警方确信他故意针对年轻母亲，通过威胁要伤害她们的孩子来控制受害者。幸存者提供的描述使得人们能够绘制出一幅强奸犯的复合素描，并在警方和公众中广泛传阅。嫌疑人年龄在34至44岁之间，肤色苍白，身高在5英尺4英寸到5英尺10英寸之间，
tall and had sandy light brown or reddish-blonde hair with long bushy sideburns. As more details came to light, police tasked a sculptor with creating a bust of the perpetrator. The first time a three-dimensional likeness was made of a wanted man in Australia. Eight survivors and two witnesses from the most recent crimes helped design the sculpture, which took 45 hours to build. A hairdresser coloured and combed a wig and a makeup artist added skin tones to the bust, which police nicknamed Boris. Boris was used to gain the public's assistance in identifying its real-life counterpart, who was described as having soft hands, being well-spoken and often going barefoot. A few survivors thought he had a slight accent that
身材高挑，留着沙黄色或红金色头发以及长而浓密的络腮胡。随着更多细节浮出水面，警方委托一位雕塑家制作了一尊肇事者的半身像。这是澳大利亚历史上首次为一个通缉犯制作三维塑像。来自最近几起案件的八名幸存者和两名证人协助设计了这座雕塑，耗时45小时才完成。一名发型师为假发染了色并梳理了发型，一名化妆师为半身像添加了肤色，警方给这个半身像取了个绰号叫“鲍里斯”。“鲍里斯”被用来争取公众的协助，以识别现实生活中的嫌疑人。据描述，此人双手柔嫩，谈吐优雅，经常赤脚。一些幸存者认为他带有轻微的口音，
might have been Scottish or Northern English. Another descriptor that appeared in several survivor's statements was that their attacker had an offensive odour, described as a combination of strong cigarette smoke, body odour, bitumen or diesel. As such, a newspaper sub-editor dubbed The Unknown Rapist, Mr Stinky. In 1982, five individual sets of fingerprints associated with the state's most notorious unsolved crimes were prominently displayed in the Office of the Victoria Police Fingerprint Bureau, in the hope that staff would memorise and recognise them instantly. Among them were the fingerprints belonging to Mr Stinky. The Bureau had no computers, so the team of 67 men and women would spend every day sifting
可能是苏格兰口音或英格兰北部口音。几位幸存者的陈述中出现的另一个描述是，她们的袭击者有一种令人不快的体味，被形容为浓烈烟草味、体味、沥青或柴油味的结合体。因此，一家报纸的副主编给这位不知名的强奸犯起名为“臭先生”。1982年，与该州最臭名昭著的未破案件相关的五组独立指纹被显眼地展示在维多利亚州警察指纹局办公室里，希望工作人员能立即记住并认出它们。其中包括属于“臭先生”的指纹。当时局里还没有电脑，因此这支由67名男女组成的团队每天都要花时间筛选
through hundreds of polaroid photographs taken at crime scenes to find matching characteristics with prints on file. On Monday, July 12, Sergeant Andrew Wall decided to examine some fingerprints from cold case files and came across the ones lifted from the top of the driver's side door of Gary Haywood's F.J. Holden sedan 16 years earlier. The prints, which were suspected to belong to Gary Haywood and Abinah Madill's killer, showed impressions of an individual's right middle and ring fingers. They immediately appeared familiar to Sergeant Wall, who quickly realised they matched those belonging to Mr Stinky. Although this breakthrough didn't bring authorities any closer to identifying Mr Stinky, it offered them a new suspect in the double homicide.
数百张在犯罪现场拍摄的宝丽星照片，以寻找与存档指纹相匹配的特征。7月12日星期一，安德鲁·沃尔中士决定检查几份冷案档案中的指纹，偶然发现了16年前从加里·海伍德的FJ霍顿轿车司机侧车门顶部提取的指纹。这些被怀疑属于加里·海伍德和阿比娜·麦迪尔凶手的指纹，显示了一个人右手中指和无名指的印记。沃尔中士对这些指纹立刻感到眼熟，他很快意识到它们与属于“臭先生”的指纹相吻合。尽管这一突破并没有让当局更接近于识别“臭先生”，但它为他们提供了一个这起双重谋杀案的新嫌疑人。
On January 4, 1983, the development saw the reward for information about the crime increase from $10,000 to $50,000. In May the following year, a new task force was formed to identify and apprehend Mr Stinky. Headquartered at the offices of the Victorian Police Academy in the Melbourne suburb of Glen Waverly, the team comprised of four detectives who were led by Detective Senior Sergeant Dennis Hanna. Within two weeks, they added a 13th rape to the list of attacks attributed to Mr Stinky. This most recent assault had occurred several weeks earlier and within a kilometre of the task force's base. Given the perpetrator was still active, the team understood the urgency of their task. People who had crossed paths with the 13 survivors were examined in an
1983年1月4日，这一进展使得有关该犯罪线索的悬赏金从10,000美元增加到50,000美元。次年5月，一个新的特别工作组成立，旨在识别和抓捕“臭先生”。该团队总部设在墨尔本格伦韦弗利郊区的维多利亚警察学院办公室，由四名侦探组成，由侦探高级警长丹尼斯·汉纳领导。在两周内，他们将第13起强奸案添加到了归咎于“臭先生”的袭击名单中。这起最新的袭击发生在前几周，地点就在工作组基地一公里以内。鉴于肇事者依然活跃，团队意识到了他们任务的紧迫性。曾与这13名幸存者有过交集的人员受到了审查，以
effort to find a connection between them. A computer database was created of individuals who had been in shepherden in the 1960s and Melbourne's eastern suburbs during the 1970s, with investigators planning to cross-check the extensive lists to see if there was any overlap between the categories. Details from other cases were also studied to uncover more potential victims or perpetrators. Mr Stinky's fingerprints were circulated to police stations throughout Australia and in July 1984, two detectives were sent to the Central Fingerprint Bureau in Sydney to spend a week searching through their databases for a match. Though their efforts came up dry, they left copies of Mr Stinky's prints for Sydney detectives to keep on file.
努力寻找他们之间的联系。一个电脑数据库被建立起来，其中收录了在20世纪60年代在谢帕顿以及在70年代在墨尔本东区活动过的人员信息，调查人员计划对这些庞大的名单进行交叉比对，看看这些类别之间是否有任何重叠。其他案件的细节也被研究，以挖掘更多潜在的受害者或肇事者。“臭先生”的指纹被分发到澳大利亚各地的警察局，1984年7月，两名侦探被派往悉尼中央指纹局，花了一周时间在他们的数据库中搜寻匹配项。尽管他们的努力一无所获，但他们留下了“臭先生”指纹的副本，供悉尼侦探存档。
With no significant progress achieved by the end of 1984, the task force was disbanded and its detectives were ordered to return to their normal duties. The town of Aubrey is nestled on the northern banks of the Murray River, which acts as a watery border between the states of New South Wales and Victoria to the south. On Saturday, March 16, 1985, local resident Pat Halpin was operating a cash register in the electrical goods department at Aubrey's Walton's department store, where she'd worked for 30 years. In between serving customers, Pat would gaze out the large display windows nearby, people watching and keeping an eye on passers-by. As lunchtime drew near,
由于在1984年底之前没有取得重大进展，该特别工作组被解散，其侦探被命令返回各自的正常岗位。奥尔伯里镇坐落在墨累河北岸，该河是新南威尔士州与南部维多利亚州之间的水上边界。1985年3月16日星期六，当地居民帕特·哈尔平正在奥尔伯里沃尔顿百货公司的电器部操作一台收银机，她已经在那里工作了30年。在服务顾客的间隙，帕特会凝视附近的大型展示窗，观察行人并留意过往的人。随着午餐时间临近，
she noticed a beefy man with a pop-belly and sandy-coloured hair sitting in a Ford station wagon outside, parked parallel to the curb. He was wearing a blue singlet and had the driver's seat tilted back in a reclining position. Pat looked away, but found her attention drawn back to the man several minutes later. She noticed that he had a tense expression on his face before realizing he was masturbating. Pat alerted a number of other employees and the store's manager called the police. Two police cars containing three constables arrived at approximately 12.30pm and parked at the rear of the store to avoid alerting the man to their presence. Constable Glenn Taylor approached the vehicle and tapped on the window, shocking the car's occupant.
她注意到外面有一名身材魁梧、挺着大肚子、留着沙黄色头发的男子坐在福特旅行车里，车子与路边平行停放。他穿着一件蓝色背心，司机座椅向后倾斜呈躺姿。帕特移开视线，但几分钟后发现自己的注意力又被那名男子吸引了过去。她注意到他脸上有紧张的表情，随后意识到他正在手淫。帕特提醒了其他几名员工，商店经理随即报警。两辆载有三名警员的警车大约在中午12点30分到达，并停在商店后方，以避免让该男子察觉到他们的存在。格伦·泰勒警员走近车辆并敲了敲车窗，吓了车内的人一跳。
The man initially denied any wrongdoing, but grew quiet when he realized he had been caught. When asked what his name was, he replied, Raymond Edmonds. While the other two officers took statements from witnesses, Constable Kevin Savage took Edmonds into custody and charged him with willful and obscene exposure. He had his fingerprints taken in accordance with New South Wales law, which dictated that all offenders be fingerprinted. On Monday, March 18, 41-year-old Raymond Edmonds pleaded guilty in an Orbrie Court and was fined $400 before being released. As per standard procedure, Edmonds' fingerprints were sent to the Central Fingerprint Bureau in Sydney for filing.
这名男子最初否认有任何不当行为，但在意识到自己被抓个正着时变得安静下来。当被问及他的名字时，他回答说，雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹。当另外两名警官记录证人口供时，凯文·萨维奇警员将埃德蒙兹拘留，并指控他犯有故意猥亵暴露罪。根据新南威尔士州法律的规定，所有违法者都必须按指纹，因此他被采集了指纹。3月18日星期一，41岁的雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹在奥尔伯里法院对指控供认不讳，被罚款400美元后获释。按照标准程序，埃德蒙兹的指纹被发送到悉尼中央指纹局存档。
Several days later, at around 5pm on Thursday, March 21, Raymond Edmonds' fingerprints were examined by a senior detective working late at Sydney's Central Fingerprint Bureau. The index fingers were strongly defined, while a scar cut across the little finger on the right hand. He immediately recognized them as matching a set of prints that Victorian detectives had left at the office eight months prior, that belonged to a serial rapist and suspected killer known only as Mr Stinky. Raymond Edmonds was born in Melbourne on March 12, 1944. As his birth mother was young and unwed, Edmonds was adopted by a married couple named Harold and Tamaevis Edmonds, though he wouldn't
几天后，即3月21日星期四下午5点左右，雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹的指纹在悉尼中央指纹局被一位加班的高级侦探检查。他的食指纹路清晰，而右手小指上有一道伤疤。他一眼就认出这与八个月前维多利亚州侦探留在办公室的一套指纹相吻合，该指纹属于一个只被称为“臭气先生”的连环强奸犯和疑似杀手。雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹于1944年3月12日出生于墨尔本。由于生母年轻且未婚，埃德蒙兹被一对名叫哈罗德和塔梅维斯·埃德蒙兹的夫妇收养，尽管他直到
learn of his adoption until his teenage years. He was the couple's only child and they doted on him, leading some of the family's relatives to believe he was spoiled and undisciplined. By the time Edmonds was six years old, he started exhibiting signs of being withdrawn and struggled to connect with others. Harold Edmonds was a businessman who bought and sold farms and his family often relocated to various towns throughout Victoria for his work. In the mid-1950s, when Edmonds was 13 years old, the family made their sixth move since his adoption. Around the same time, his father purchased him a gift, an automatic Mossberg 22 rifle with a fold-down grip. As a child, Edmonds had issues with bedwetting which continued through to his
青少年时期才知道自己是被收养的。他是这对夫妇唯一的孩子，他们对百般宠爱，导致一些亲戚认为他被宠坏且缺乏管教。埃德蒙兹六岁时，开始表现出性格内向的迹象，难以与他人建立联系。哈罗德·埃德蒙兹是一名买卖农场的商人，为了工作，他的家人经常搬迁到维多利亚州的各个城镇。20世纪50年代中期，埃德蒙兹13岁时，全家进行了自他被收养以来的第六次搬迁。大约在同一时间，他的父亲送给他一件礼物，一把带折叠握把的莫斯伯格22口径半自动步枪。小时候，埃德蒙兹有尿床的问题，这一问题一直持续到他
early teens. On one occasion, Mavis took her son to see a doctor for a diagnosis. The doctor found no physical cause for the problem, but noticed that Edmonds only had one testicle. He prescribed a drug to treat the issue, but later confessed to Mavis that he had prescribed the incorrect medication, one that was used to accelerate puberty. Mavis shared this information with friends, but little else is known about the matter as the doctor's records were not retained. As a teenager, Edmonds didn't form any close friendships with other boys his age and was almost exclusively fixated on sex and young women. When he was 16 years old, he impregnated a girl who gave the child up for adoption.
青少年早期。有一次，梅维斯带儿子去看医生以确诊。医生没有发现该问题的生理原因，但注意到埃德蒙兹只有一个睾丸。他开了一种药来治疗这个问题，但后来向梅维斯坦白，他开错了药，那是一种用于加速青春发育的药物。梅维斯将这一信息分享给了朋友，但由于医生的记录没有保留，关于此事知之甚少。十几岁时，埃德蒙兹没有与同龄的其他男孩建立任何亲密的友谊，几乎全神贯注于性和年轻女性。16岁时，他使一个女孩怀孕，该女孩后来将孩子送养。
At 17, Edmonds was seduced by an older woman who was a friend of his family. They participated in experimental and violent sex, and she encouraged him to watch sex acts between herself and her girlfriend. Years later, Edmonds admitted, quote, That was when my problem started. In the mid-1960s, the family resided in Yerrawonga, a township roughly 270km northeast of Melbourne, on the border of Victoria and New South Wales. It was there that he met Leslie Crawford, a tall, blond teenager two years his junior. The pair had an on-and-off relationship until Leslie broke up with Edmonds towards the end of the year. They reunited several weeks later,
17岁时，埃德蒙兹被一个比他大、是他家庭朋友的女人勾引。他们参与了试验性和暴力的性行为，她鼓励他观看她与她女友之间的性行为。多年以后，埃德蒙兹承认，原话是，“那就是我的问题开始的时候。”20世纪60年代中期，全家居住在耶拉翁加，这是墨尔本东北约270公里处、位于维多利亚州和新南威尔士州边界的一个小镇。正是在那里，他遇到了莱斯利·克劳福德，一个比他小两岁、高个子金发少女。两人分分合合，直到年底莱斯利与埃德蒙兹分手。几周后他们复合，
and on Leslie's 16th birthday, they conceived a child. Leslie's parents disliked Edmonds and offered to support their daughter and her baby themselves, but Leslie chose to stay with her child's father in the hopes they could have a happy life together. The couple married in September of 1961 and moved to a dairy farm where Edmonds and his father worked. Edmonds was unfaithful to Leslie from the outset of their marriage, but was also extremely jealous of any attention she received. When their first child was born, he refused to visit his wife in hospital, and she briefly returned to live with her parents. The couple reconciled again and soon had a second child.
在莱斯利16岁生日那天，他们怀上了孩子。莱斯利父母不喜欢埃德蒙兹，并主动提出自己抚养女儿和她的婴儿，但莱斯利选择和孩子父亲在一起，希望能过上幸福的生活。这对夫妇于1961年9月结婚，搬到了埃德蒙兹和他父亲工作的奶牛场。埃德蒙兹从婚姻一开始就对莱斯利不忠，但也极度嫉妒她受到的任何关注。他们的第一个孩子出生时，他拒绝去医院看望妻子，她短暂回家与父母同住。两人再次和解，不久后又有了第二个孩子。
Edmonds had a violent temper that could erupt at any time, and he often took his anger out on the animals he worked with. He earned a reputation for animal cruelty after he almost beat a counter death with an iron chain, an incident that deeply disturbed those who witnessed it. On another occasion, he killed a farm dog that had taken an instant dislike to him. In retaliation, a furious co-worker leapt on Edmonds and stabbed him in the arm with a knife. Leslie was also a victim of Edmonds' violence. He beat and raped her often, and abused her emotionally and financially by humiliating her in front of other people and withholding money. By the time Leslie was 19, she was pregnant with the couple's third child.
埃德蒙兹脾气暴躁，随时可能爆发，他经常把怒气发泄在他共事的动物身上。由于他曾用铁链差点打死一头牛，这一事件深深震惊了目击者，他获得了虐待动物的恶名。另有一次，他杀死了一只对他第一眼就很反感的农场狗。作为报复，一个愤怒的同事扑向埃德蒙兹，用刀刺伤了他的手臂。莱斯利也是埃德蒙兹暴力的受害者。他经常殴打和强奸她，并在众人面前羞辱她、克扣金钱，从而对她进行情感和经济上的虐待。莱斯利19岁时，怀上了两人的第三个孩子。
Around this time, she walked in on Edmonds molesting their three-year-old daughter. Leslie began to scream, and her husband simply exited the room in silence. Like his father, Edmonds never stayed in one place for too long. By 1966, Edmonds and Leslie lived with their three young children on a dairy farm in Artmona, a rural area 10km west of Shepardon. On the evening of February 10, 1966, the night Gary Haywood and Abina Madill went missing, Edmonds went out for the evening, and didn't return. The next morning, Leslie heard the news about the two missing teenagers on the radio and felt a twinge of suspicion, wondering where her husband had been the night before,
大约在这个时候，她撞见埃德蒙兹正在猥亵他们三岁的女儿。莱斯利尖叫起来，她的丈夫只是默默地走出了房间。和他的父亲一样，埃德蒙兹从不在一个地方呆太久。到1966年，埃德蒙兹和莱斯利带着三个幼小的孩子住在谢帕顿以西10公里处农村阿特莫纳的一个奶牛场里。1966年2月10日傍晚，即加里·海伍德和阿比娜·马迪尔失踪的那天晚上，埃德蒙兹外出过夜，没有回来。第二天早上，莱斯利在收音机里听到两个失踪青少年的消息，心中产生了一丝怀疑，纳闷她丈夫前天晚上到底去了哪里，
but ultimately dismissed her concerns. During the investigation into the double homicide, a police officer visited the farm in Artmona to question Edmonds, only to discover he and his family had since relocated to New South Wales. The officer indicated they would alert their interstate counterparts that Edmonds was wanted for questioning, but the lead wasn't pursued further. By 1968, Leslie had given up any hope that her husband would change. She returned to live with her parents, and as punishment, Edmonds refused to let her have any contact with their children, and she didn't see them for four years. Several years later, Edmonds began a romantic relationship with his living housekeeper, Colleen, who had two children.
但最终打消了顾虑。在对这起谋杀案的调查过程中，一名警官走访了阿特莫纳的农场盘问埃德蒙兹，却发现他和家人已经搬到了新南威尔士州。这名警官表示会提醒跨州同行埃德蒙兹因涉嫌接受盘问而被通缉，但这条线索没有进一步追踪。到1968年，莱斯利已经放弃了丈夫会改变的任何希望。她搬回父母家住，作为惩罚，埃德蒙兹拒绝让她与孩子们有任何接触，她四年没见到他们。几年后，埃德蒙兹与现任管家科琳开始了一段浪漫关系，科琳有两个孩子。
By 1971, the couple had a child together and moved to the inner Melbourne suburb of Richmond, where Edmonds took a job as a tram conductor. He officially divorced Leslie and married Colleen. By mid-1975, Edmonds was working as a night patrolman for a security firm in Melbourne's eastern suburbs, but was eager to relocate again. He moved to a farm in the Gippsland town of Officer, which was close enough to commute to Melbourne for work. At the end of 1976, he took another farm share job at a property in Chelsea Heights, a Bayside suburb in Melbourne's south. Police in Melbourne were notified as soon as the detectives in Sydney matched Edmonds'
到1971年，两人育有一子，并搬到了墨尔本内城区里士满，埃德蒙兹在那里找到了一份电车售票员的工作。他正式与莱斯利离婚，并娶了科琳。到1975年中期，埃德蒙兹在墨尔本东郊的一家保安公司担任夜间巡逻员，但渴望再次搬家。他搬到了吉普斯兰奥菲瑟镇的一个农场，那里离墨尔本很近，可以通勤上班。1976年底，他在墨尔本南部海滨郊区切尔西海茨的一处房产找到了一份农场合伙工作。悉尼的侦探刚将埃德蒙兹的指纹与“臭气先生”匹配，墨尔本警方就得到了通知。
fingerprints to those of Mr Stinky. Suspecting he was still in Orbury, arrangements were immediately made for investigators to travel there. But before that could happen, he was tracked to a factory in the Melbourne suburb of Hyatt. At 7.50 am on Friday, March 22, 1985, detectives Dennis Hanna and Ken Mansell went to the factory and instantly recognized the man behind the front desk in the foreman's office as Raymond Edmonds. He remained calm as the detectives told him he was being taken into custody for questioning over the murders of a young Shepardin couple in 1966. At the time, Victorian law only permitted police interviews to run for a maximum of six hours,
由于怀疑他仍在奥伯里，警方立即安排调查人员前往那里。但在那之前，他被追踪到墨尔本海厄特郊区的一家工厂。1985年3月22日星期五上午7点50分，侦探丹尼斯·汉纳和肯·曼塞尔前往该工厂，一眼认出工长办公室前台后方的男子就是雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹。当侦探告诉他因涉嫌1966年谋杀谢帕顿年轻夫妇而被拘留接受盘问时，他保持着镇定。当时，维多利亚州法律仅允许警方讯问最多持续六小时，
so time was of the essence for the detectives. State laws also allowed people to decline having their fingerprints or footprints taken, but Edmonds consented to both. Although his fingerprints matched those taken from Gary Haywood's vehicle, he staunchly denied any connection to the double homicide. When asked if he had been in Shepardin at the time, he evasively replied, I might and might not have been. He also denied responsibility for any of the rapes that occurred throughout Melbourne in the 1970s, but as the interview progressed, his confidence began to fade. He refused to look the investigators in the eyes, averting his gaze and giving listless responses. Shortly after 10.30 am, Edmonds finally cracked, stating, I've asked myself why many times,
因此对侦探来说时间就是一切。州法律还允许人们拒绝提取指纹或足迹，但埃德蒙兹两者都同意了。尽管他的指纹与加里·海伍德车上提取的指纹相符，但他坚决否认与这起双重谋杀案有任何关联。当被问及当时是否在谢帕顿时，他 evasively 回答：“我可能去过，也可能没去过。”他还否认对20世纪70年代墨尔本发生的所有强奸案负有责任，但随着讯问的进行，他的自信开始减退。他拒绝直视调查人员的眼睛，避开目光，并给出倦怠的回答。上午10点30分刚过，埃德蒙兹终于崩溃了，说：“我多次问过自己，
I don't want to hurt anyone anymore. Although he wasn't religious, he asked the detectives to contact a priest whom he could confess his crimes to, who could then relay the information to police. A Catholic priest was summoned and the pair spoke in privacy for 15 minutes before the detectives were called back into the room, with Edmonds agreeing to repeat his confession. On the night of February 10, 1966, Edmonds claimed he went to Shepardin and met a large group of people outside a hotel on the town's main street, who introduced him to Gary Haywood and Abinah Medill. When the rest of the group left to attend the mod spectacular concert at
我再也不想伤害任何人了。”尽管他没有宗教信仰，但他要求侦探联系一位神父，他可以向其忏悔自己的罪行，然后由神父将信息转达给警方。一名天主教神父被召来，两人私下交谈了15分钟，然后侦探被叫回房间，埃德蒙兹同意重复他的忏悔。1966年2月10日晚上，埃德蒙兹声称他去了谢帕顿，在镇主街的一家酒店外遇到了一大群人，他们把他介绍给了加里·海伍德和阿比娜·梅迪尔。当其余的人离开去观看
the Civic Centre, Gary and Abinah invited him to go for a drive in Gary's car. During the course of the drive, Edmonds claimed that Abinah climbed into the backseat and they engaged in consensual sex, which made Gary angry and jealous. As he drove, Gary revealed he was carrying a .22 caliber automatic sawn-off rifle and started shooting out the driver's side window. They eventually arrived at the rural Riverside Village of Merchison, where Edmonds and Gary went for a walk. They got into an argument about Abinah and Edmonds shot Gary. When he returned to the car and told Abinah that Gary was dead, she tried to run away, but Edmonds chased her and beat her to death. He claimed he had ditched the murder weapon near her body, despite it never being recovered from
市民中心的现代盛大音乐会时，加里和阿比娜邀请他坐加里的车兜风。在车行驶过程中，埃德蒙兹声称阿比娜爬到了后座，他们发生了合意的性行为，这让加里感到愤怒和嫉妒。开车时，加里透露他随身携带一支.22口径自动锯短步枪，并开始朝驾驶座侧窗外射击。他们最终到达了农村河滨村庄马奇森，埃德蒙兹和加里下车散步。他们就阿比娜发生了争执，埃德蒙兹开枪打死了加里。当他回到车里告诉阿比娜加里已死时，她试图逃跑，但埃德蒙兹追赶并将其殴打致死。他声称自己把凶器扔在了她尸体附近，尽管该凶器从未在
the scene. Edmonds concluded his confession by saying, I'm fit and healthy, but I must be sick in the head. I think I need destroying. The detectives showed Edmonds a film made in 1966 that recreated the movements of Gary Haywood's car on the night of February 10. He identified the teenagers F.J. Holden as well as various local landmarks. While this confirmed he had knowledge of the crime, the detectives didn't believe his version of events in the slightest, as many key details didn't add up. Physical evidence indicated the victims had been tied up, but Edmonds claimed he had no memory of doing this. In addition, several witness statements placed Gary and Abinah away from the hotel during the period
现场被找到。埃德蒙兹在忏悔结束时说：“我身体健康，但我脑子一定有病。我觉得我需要被消灭。”侦探向埃德蒙兹展示了一部拍摄于1966年的电影，该片重现了2月10日晚加里·海伍德汽车的行踪。他认出了青少年的F.J.霍顿以及各种当地地标。虽然这证实了他对犯罪情况有所了解，但侦探一点也不相信他的作案版本，因为许多关键细节根本对不上。物证表明受害者曾被绑架，但埃德蒙兹声称对此毫无记忆。此外，几名证人的证言表明，在
Edmonds claimed to have met them there. He also denied ever owning a firearm and claimed the rifle belonged to Gary Haywood, but Gary's family established he had never owned a gun. Raymond Edmonds was formally charged with the double homicide. He was also charged with three counts of rape and two counts of assault with intent to rape in relation to five attacks committed by the Donvale rapist. When his wife Colleen asked if he really murdered the two teenagers, he admitted, yes. Word of the arrest spread through Shepardon, providing both relief and sorrow to the families of the victims and those wrongfully accused. At the time of Gary Haywood and Abinah Madill's murders, Edmonds was 21 years old and worked at
埃德蒙兹声称在那里遇到他们的期间，加里和阿比娜并不在酒店。他还否认拥有任何枪支，并声称这支步枪属于加里·海伍德，但加里的家人证实他从未拥有过枪。雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹被正式指控犯有双重谋杀罪。他还因唐瓦尔强奸犯犯下的五起袭击事件而被指控三项强奸罪和两项意图强奸未遂罪。当他的妻子科琳问他是否真的谋杀了这两个青少年时，他承认了，是的。逮捕的消息在谢帕顿传开，给受害者家属和被冤枉的人带来了宽慰和悲伤。在加里·海伍德和阿比娜·马迪尔谋杀案发生时，埃德蒙兹21岁，在
a dairy farm in Art Mona that belonged to the Gorn family. He got along well with the family's 16-year-old son, Stuart, and the pair often went out shooting foxes and rabbits together. In 1985, Stuart was in his mid-30s and still resided on the dairy farm. When he heard the news that Raymond Edmonds had been arrested for the infamous double homicide, he immediately recognized his name and recalled that a detective had visited the farm following the murders looking for Edmonds. At the time, the Gorn family had assumed his name must have come up when police were looking for Mossberg rifle owners. News of the arrest also prompted Stuart to remember that years earlier, he had found a cut-off piece of a gun stock and a telescopic sight from a rifle
属于戈恩家族位于阿特莫纳的奶牛场工作。他与该家族16岁的儿子斯图尔特相处融洽，两人经常一起出去射杀狐狸和兔子。1985年，斯图尔特30多岁，仍然住在奶牛场。当他听到雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹因臭名昭著的双重谋杀案被捕的消息时，他立刻认出了这个名字，并记起谋杀案发生后曾有一名侦探访问农场寻找埃德蒙兹。当时，戈恩家族以为警方在寻找莫斯伯格步枪所有者时才会提到他的名字。逮捕的消息还促使斯图尔特想起多年前，他在埃德蒙兹在农场工作期间
in a shed that Edmonds had used during his time on the farm. He called the Shepardon police to report the discoveries. This information was hugely significant for investigators, as they had not retained records of the officer visiting the farm in 1966 to question Edmonds and were unaware that he ever owned a Mossberg rifle. On Sunday, March 24, detectives visited the Gorn's dairy farm to collect the items. Stuart showed them a spot where he and Edmonds used to shoot targets and the decision was made to dig for ballistic evidence. A large quantity of soil was excavated from the area, revealing 9 22-caliber cartridge cases that matched those found near the bodies of Abinah Medill and Gary Haywood 20 years earlier. Forensic evidence also confirmed
使用过的一个棚子里发现了一段被截断的枪托和一个步枪瞄准镜。他打电话给谢帕顿警方报告了这一发现。这对调查人员来说极为重要，因为他们没有保留1966年警官走访农场盘问埃德蒙兹的记录，也不知道他曾拥有一支莫斯伯格步枪。3月24日星期日，侦探们走访了戈恩的奶牛场收集这些物品。斯图尔特向他们展示了他和埃德蒙兹过去常用来射击靶子的地点，并决定挖掘弹道证据。该地区出土了大量土壤，发现了9枚.22口径弹壳，与20年前在阿比娜·梅迪尔和加里·海伍德尸体附近发现的弹壳相吻合。法医证据还证实
that the pieces of the gun stock and the telescopic sight would fit a .352K model Mossberg. Despite Edmonds' confession, he was yet to enter a plea and was reminded in custody while detectives continued building a case against him. They traced his movements over the years and discovered that unsolved sexual assaults had occurred in every area he had resided. Investigators believed Edmonds was responsible for 27 other rape and assault cases, but he had since retained a lawyer and refused to respond to any subsequent questioning. Without a formal interview, police were unable to press charges. They conducted extensive interviews with Edmonds ex-wife Leslie and his current
枪托和瞄准镜的碎片将适合.352K型号的莫斯伯格。尽管埃德蒙兹供认不讳，但他尚未进行抗辩，并在侦探继续建立针对他的案件时被还押候审。他们追踪了他多年来的行踪，发现他住过的每个地区都发生过未破的性侵案。调查人员认为埃德蒙兹应对其他27起强奸和袭击案负责，但他随后聘请了律师，拒绝回答任何随后的讯问。没有正式的讯问，警方无法提起指控。他们对埃德蒙兹的前妻莱斯利和现任
spouse Colleen, uncovering detailed information about his violent and sexually abusive tendencies. Leslie admitted that she had intuitively believed Edmonds could be responsible for the murders of Gary Haywood and Abinah Medill from the start, but refrained from going to the police because she didn't truly think he was capable of the crime. She had also been concerned that her suspicions would be dismissed as an unhappy wife trying to get her husband in trouble. Investigators compiled 260 pages of statements taken from 66 witnesses and managed to debunk Edmonds' original confession, confirming that his father had given him a Mossberg rifle when he was a teenager. A 5,000-word summary of the case was prepared ahead of Edmonds' committal hearing,
配偶科琳进行了广泛的讯问，揭露了他暴力和性虐待倾向的详细信息。莱斯利承认，她从一开始就凭直觉认为埃德蒙兹可能是加里·海伍德和阿比娜·马迪尔谋杀案的凶手，但没有报警，因为她并不真正认为他有能力犯下这起罪行。她还担心自己的怀疑会被当作一个不快乐的妻子试图让丈夫陷入麻烦而被驳回。调查人员汇编了从66名证人那里收集的260页证词，并设法驳斥了埃德蒙兹最初的供词，证实他的父亲在他十几岁时送给他一把莫斯伯格步枪。一份5000字的案件摘要在埃德蒙兹的预审听证会前准备好，
with detectives outlining their theory that the accused had kidnapped his victims when they were sitting in Gary's holden near Lake Victoria. He then held them at gunpoint, forcing Gary to drive to Merchison East, where he restrained him with stockings before raping Abinah. Gary likely managed to break free, prompting Edmonds to shoot him before finally killing Abinah. On Monday, October 21, 1985, Edmonds' committal hearing commenced at the Melbourne Magistrates Court, where he pleaded not guilty to all seven charges. Evidence was presented over five days, after which the magistrate concluded there was enough evidence for the case to proceed the trial. While awaiting trial, Edmonds changed his plea to guilty of all charges.
侦探们概述了他们的理论，即被告在受害者坐在维多利亚湖附近的加里霍顿车里时绑架了他们。然后他用枪指着他们，迫使加里开车去马奇森东，在那里他用丝袜限制了加里，然后强奸了阿比娜。加里可能设法挣脱，促使埃德蒙兹开枪打死他，最后杀死了阿比娜。1985年10月21日星期一，埃德蒙兹的预审听证会在墨尔本治安法院开始，他在那里对所有七项指控均表示不认罪。证据出示了五天，之后治安法官得出结论，认为有足够的证据使案件进入审判阶段。在等待审判期间，埃德蒙兹将他的抗辩改为对所有指控认罪。
On Thursday, April 3, 1986, he appeared at the Melbourne Supreme Court to receive his sentencing. The State of Victoria abolished capital punishment in 1975, meaning had Edmonds been caught in 1966 when he carried out the murders, he would have faced the death penalty. Instead, for the murders of Gary Haywood and Abinah Medill, he was sentenced to two terms of life imprisonment, with no minimum term. Sentencing for the three rapes and two attempted sexual assaults took place on Tuesday, October 28, 1986. Justice Alistair Nicholson remarked, You chose women who were alone or who were caring for young children as your prey. You attacked them at night in what must have been horrifying circumstances. In four cases,
1986年4月3日星期四，他出现在墨尔本最高法院接受判决。维多利亚州于1975年废除了死刑，这意味着如果埃德蒙兹在1966年作案时被抓，他将面临死刑。相反，因谋杀加里·海伍德和阿比纳·梅迪尔，他被判处两项无期徒刑，且无假释最低期限。对三起强奸罪和两起未遂性侵罪的宣判于1986年10月28日星期二进行。法官阿拉斯泰尔·尼科尔森评论道：“你选择独自一人或照顾幼童的女性作为猎物。你在夜间袭击她们，那一定是极其恐怖的环境。在四起案件中，”
you had a knife. The fact that you raped these women with children in bed with them just didn't matter to you. You treated women as some sort of inferior species upon which you could inflict your desires. He then sentenced Edmonds to an additional 30 years. Following his older brother's murder, Alan Haywood had been consumed by thoughts of vengeance. In a 1987 interview with the journalist and author Andrew Rule, Alan revealed how his family had struggled to cope in the aftermath of the violent crime. Though his father was still alive, his mother's health deteriorated following Gary's death, and she passed away nine years later. For months after the murders, Alan carried a sawn-off rifle in his school bag,
“你都带着一把刀。你强奸这些女性时，她们的孩子就在旁边的床上，而你对此全然不在乎。你把女性当作某种劣等物种，可以随心所欲地发泄你的欲望。”随后，法官判处埃德蒙兹额外30年监禁。在哥哥被谋杀后，阿兰·海伍德一直被复仇的念头折磨。在1987年接受记者兼作家安德鲁·鲁尔的采访时，阿兰透露了他的家人如何在暴力犯罪发生后艰难求生。尽管他的父亲仍然在世，但母亲的健康在加里死后急剧恶化，并在九年后去世。谋杀案发生后的几个月里，阿兰的书包里一直藏着一把截短步枪，
terrified that his brother's killer would pursue him next. He practiced shooting and became a crack shot, hoping the opportunity for revenge would one day present itself. When Raymond Edmonds was arrested, Alan thought his chance had finally arrived and considered attending the committal hearing to execute the murderer himself. His wife talked him out of it by pointing out that revenge was futile, as he would only be putting his family through more suffering and destroying his own life. In 1988, Andrew Rule published a book about Edmonds' crimes titled Cuckoo. In it, he described how a number of Edmonds' survivors experienced ongoing trauma and suffered personal
生怕他哥哥的杀手下一个就会找上他。他练习射击并成为了一名神枪手，希望有一天能有报仇的机会。当雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹被捕时，阿兰认为自己的机会终于来了，并考虑出席预审听证会，亲手处决这个杀人犯。他的妻子说服了他，指出复仇是徒劳的，因为那只会让他的家人经受更多痛苦，并毁掉他自己的人生。1988年，安德鲁·鲁尔出版了一本关于埃德蒙兹罪行的书，名为《杜鹃鸟》。他在书中描述了埃德蒙兹的几名幸存者如何在经历创伤和遭受个人
losses as a result of his crimes, but found support in one another and the detectives who investigated their cases. Since his capture, Raymond Edmonds has been considered a suspect in several other high-profile, cult cases. During his first police interview on March 22, 1985, Edmonds became morose and began to make references towards the murders of two other young women, but the six-hour interview limit was reached before the detectives could question him further. The first was 17-year-old Bronwyn Richardson, who was abducted outside a supermarket in Aubrey in October 1973. Her semi-naked body was discovered in the Murray River two days later, with an autopsy revealing she had been raped and strangled. Her clothes were folded neatly nearby,
损失后，在彼此以及调查案件的侦探身上找到了支持。自被捕以来，雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹一直被认为是其他几起备受瞩目的重大悬案的嫌疑人。在1985年3月22日的首次警方讯问中，埃德蒙兹变得阴郁，并开始提及对另外两名年轻女性谋杀案的线索，但在侦探能够进一步盘问他之前，六小时的讯问时间限制已到。第一起是17岁的布朗温·理查森，她于1973年10月在奥尔伯里的一家超市外被绑架。两天后，人们在墨累河发现了她半裸的尸体，尸检显示她遭到强奸和勒死。她的衣服整齐地叠放在附近，
in a similar manner to the way a Benham-Adil's clothing had been found in 1966. Several men have been charged with Bronwyn's murder over the years, but the case has never preceded the trial. The second crime took place on Thursday, January 3, 1980. 39-year-old Elaine Jones was camping with her husband, Alan, and their two children in the Riverside town of Toquemore, near the New South Wales and Victorian border. She walked to a shop two kilometers away to buy chocolates and cigarettes, but never returned. The following morning, Alan and their seven-year-old daughter discovered Elaine's naked body in the Murray River while out in their dinghy. She had been sexually assaulted, her skull was fractured,
这与1966年发现本哈姆-阿迪尔衣物的方式相似。多年来，几名男子曾被指控谋杀布朗温，但该案从未进入审判阶段。第二起犯罪发生于1980年1月3日星期四。39岁的伊莱恩·琼斯和丈夫阿兰以及两个孩子在新南威尔士州和维多利亚州边境附近的河畔小镇托奎莫尔露营。她步行到两公里外的一家商店买巧克力和香烟，却再也没有回来。第二天早上，阿兰和他们七岁的女儿在划小艇时，在墨累河发现了伊莱恩赤裸的尸体。她遭到性侵，头骨骨折，
and her throat had been cut. As Alan attempted to pull her body into the boat, he suffered a heart attack and died, resulting in their daughter having to swim to shore alone to seek help. Raymond Edmonds was reported to have been camping 17 kilometers away on a loopner island at the time, leaving the campsite the same night that Elaine disappeared. Edmonds has also been linked to the unsolved disappearance of eight-year-old Ella Wase Warlage, who was abducted from her home in the Bayside suburb of Beaumaris on the night of Monday, January 12, 1976. Her home was 14 kilometers northwest from the Chelsea Heights farmhouse that Edmonds moved into later that same year. In 2003, an inquest into Ella Wase's disappearance
喉咙被割断。当阿兰试图将她的尸体拉上船时，他心脏病发作身亡，导致他们的女儿不得不独自游回岸边寻求帮助。据报道，雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹当时正在17公里外的一个小岛上露营，并在伊莱恩失踪的当晚离开营地。埃德蒙兹还与8岁女孩埃拉·瓦斯·瓦尔拉杰未解的失踪案有关，她于1976年1月12日星期一晚从拜赛德滨海郊区博马里斯的家中被绑架。她的家位于埃德蒙兹同年晚些时候搬入的切尔西海茨农舍西北14公里处。2003年，关于埃拉·瓦斯失踪案的死因研讯
mentioned that Edmonds had been investigated in relation to the case, but no conclusive evidence was uncovered proving his involvement. He has also been listed as a person of interest in the slayings of six women in Tainong North, covered in episode 46 of case file, but was ultimately dismissed as a suspect. Demandatory process in New South Wales of fingerprinting all offenders was crucial to the eventual apprehension of Edmonds. At the time, Victoria lacked a similar policy, and had Edmonds been arrested across the border, he may have gone undetected. Since then, Victoria has been an early adopter of forensic advancements, and was the first state
提到埃德蒙兹曾就该案接受调查，但没有发现确凿证据证明他参与其中。他也被列为塔伊农北部六名女性遇害案的关注对象，该案曾在“案件档案”第 46 集里报道过，但最终被排除嫌疑。新南威尔士州对所有违法者进行指纹采集的强制程序，对于最终抓获埃德蒙兹至关重要。当时，维多利亚州缺乏类似政策，如果埃德蒙兹是在边界另一侧被捕，他可能就不会被发觉。自那以后，维多利亚州一直是法医技术进步的早期采用者，并成为澳大利亚第一个
in Australia to introduce widespread criminal DNA testing in the early 1990s. In 2002, Victoria was also the first to introduce the requirement that all offenders of serious crimes provide DNA samples. In 2017, the cold case team of Victoria's sexual crime squad launched a review of the investigations into crimes suspected to have been committed by Raymond Edmonds. In January 2019, he was charged with 31 historical offences relating to 11 different incidents that took place across six Melbourne suburbs beginning in 1971. The charges included eight counts of rape, three counts of indecent assault, one of abduction of a female by force, two counts of false imprisonment,
在20世纪90年代初引入广泛罪犯DNA测试的州。2002年，维多利亚州也成为第一个要求所有严重罪犯提供DNA样本的州。2017年，维多利亚州性犯罪调查组的积案小组对雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹涉嫌犯下的罪行调查进行了审查。2019年1月，他被指控犯有31起历史罪行，这些罪行涉及自1971年起发生在墨尔本六个郊区的11起不同事件。指控包括八项强奸罪、三项猥亵侵犯罪、一项暴力劫持女性罪、两项非法拘禁罪、
one count of grievous bodily harm, and ten counts of burglary. On Wednesday, September 11, 2019, the now 75-year-old Raymond Edmonds formally pleaded guilty to all of the new charges. Two weeks later, he was sentenced to an additional 23 years and five months on top of his existing life sentences. Following the announcement of these charges, Detective Inspector Steve Wilson of the sexual crime squad told the media, I want victims to feel heartened that we are charging someone this week over incidents that occurred as much as 47 years ago. It is never too late for you to speak to police, to come forward and tell your story or make a report. I also want offenders to understand that police won't give up
一项严重人身伤害罪和十项入室盗窃罪。2019年9月11日星期三，现年75岁的雷蒙德·埃德蒙兹正式对所有新指控表示认罪。两周后，他在现有无期徒刑的基础上被判处额外23年零5个月监禁。这些指控宣布后，性犯罪调查组的侦探督察史蒂夫·威尔逊对媒体表示：“我希望受害者们能感到欣慰，我们在本周对发生在多达47年前的事件提出了指控。向警察倾诉、站出来讲述你的故事或报案，永远都不会太晚。我也希望违法者明白，警方绝不会放弃
trying to provide these victims with the justice they deserve. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
为这些受害者伸张她们应得的正义的努力。该集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。